I tweet that and then I finished the day
and I wake up the next morning and I
glance at my phone I'm seeing all these
verified accounts that are you know
quote tweeting it and demanding a
retraction and whatever and I go oh okay
this looks like it's getting looks like
it's getting some attention
um I then continue about my day around
noon I hear from my dad that he got a
hundred messages from you should have
aborted your son to we're gonna find all
of you to whatever else my dad has no
idea what's going on he's like I don't
know what this is but I have a hundred
DMs
to everything else you can imagine and
I start to get emails about you know we
you know your Jewish faith this and that
and the other thing and so at that point
to me I thought this is just going to
get worse and worse and worse and so I
deleted the tweet and I really regret
doing that because over the 48 hours
that followed yes the attacks escalated
it went through Candace Owens and then
at foxnews.com Newsmax kind of peaking
with with Donald Trump Jr and it was
horrible
the following is a conversation with
David packman a left-wing Progressive
political commentator and host of the
David backman show I hope to continue to
have many conversations on politics with
prominent insightful and sometimes
controversial figures across the
political Spectrum David and I have been
planning to speak for a long time and
I'm sure we'll speak many more times
this conversation was challenging
eye-opening and fun
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's David backman
are there interesting differences to you
between terms like liberal Democrat
left-wing leftist Progressive Socialist
Communist Marxist far left Center left
all these labels is there interesting
distinctions between them yeah there's
two sets of distinctions one is if you
just want to say let's define each of
these as political terms they're all
different terms you can be a progressive
ideologically but not be a member of the
democratic party many say the Democratic
party isn't even really very Progressive
so these are certainly terms that we
could Define uh in order to have a
conversation about the next thing kind
of as a precursor to a conversation
sometimes the terms are used in order to
tag someone with a certain ideology
that's not really linked to policy or
any particular political question but
they can be used positively or
negatively to just kind of say here is
the image of this individual that I have
in my mind so like Marxist is right now
very popularly being used by some on the
right
um to attack Democrats there's very few
actual marxists certainly not in
positions of power in the United States
but even among the general population
so I think it's important to distinguish
are we defining these terms because we
want to compare and contrast the ideas
that a particular group might bring to
the discussion or are we using them as
insults or to stifle conversation there
are terms that can be used to start
conversation or to stop it and the use
of those terms is evolving rapidly month
by month so the term leftist I think is
a relatively popular term now to use the
negative context to describe
what an outraged left-wing commentator I
think what you're kind of grasping onto
is that there's probably some set of
ideas that would apply to most of those
who consider themselves to be on the
left the discussion of how that term is
mostly being used is not about policy
ideas you're accurately kind of uh
identifying that and it does seem like
Progressive is no longer being used as a
smear and leftist is being used as a
smear more at this point okay but
sometimes some of these terms are useful
like can we try to
pick the terms that are useful like
liberal and Progressive and Democrat
liberal and Progressive is there an
interesting definable distinction
between liberal and Progressive to you
that's a maybe one of the most
interesting ones 10 years ago liberal
often meant what now we mean by
Progressive
more recently the progressive
socialist-leaning part of the political
Spectrum has started to use liberal to
Mean Joe Biden to mean someone who is
not really left enough so liberal is
very interesting because I remember
talking with my audience years ago maybe
eight years ago or something like that
where I identified I'm going to now use
the term Progressive more commonly to
describe my own beliefs because liberal
has now been made a smear it's being
shifted into something else and it also
means more of like a center-left
politics so it's changed in some sense
by by necessity by force and also
because the the Spectrum has shifted to
some degree so the term liberal has
evolved
now liberal meaning some kind of uh
embodiment of the mainstream Democratic
party almost to some degree sometimes
I'm called I'm written off by you know
within my space there are all sorts of
Shades of Gray which I'm sure we can
talk about about where I am versus
should be could be or I'm wrongly placed
and sometimes an attack on me is he's
just a lib meaning I'm not left enough
I'm not Progressive socialist wherever
else you want to go so yeah the the
problem with a lot of these terms and
they're used very casually by people who
call into my show is that unless we
actually Define them each time they very
often mean very different things to
different people and often come with an
agenda attached to them and so I find
that they often stifle meaningful
conversation rather than encourage it do
you sense that there's a drifting
of uh what is the threshold to be a
progressive or is is there it should be
used Progressive synonymously with the
Democratic socialists
I think we should not use it
synonymously with Democratic Socialist
and this is where there's another
linguistic confusion and a political
confusion so we'll first talk about the
linguistic one social democracy versus
Democratic socialism very similar words
in a different order okay
my the way I operate is democratic
socialism is actually a form of
Socialism where one would seek to
socialize ownership of the means of
production as an example social
democracy is a very uh highly regulated
form of capitalism the likes of which we
would see in northern Europe Denmark Etc
these are very different things I
associate progressivism in 2023 with
social democracy and would consider
Democratic socialism a form of actual
socialism that is different it is we're
no longer talking about a capitalist
organization of society so transition
from one to the other is a fundamental
shift in house in how Society operates
then absolutely and when you talk about
social democracy you're talking about
socializing a couple more things than we
socialize in most modern uh capitalist
countries I had this conversation with
Patrick David recently social democracy
is okay we've socialized the military
already in the United States we've
socialized some health care in the sense
of like the VA and Medicaid Etc we're
talking about socializing a couple more
things still in a capitalist country
Democratic socialism would be something
beyond that and and as someone who is
not a Democratic Socialist myself I'm
I'm maybe not the best
advocate for explaining exactly how that
system would function but it would have
some version of socializing ownership of
the means of production businesses Etc
so you mentioned you appeared on the pbd
podcast with Patrick bad David
um the debate was pretty intense
I I wasn't I I should say I personally
enjoyed it I thought uh actually you did
well and I thought Patrick did well it
was a good conversation there was a
little bit of tension yeah and I I
thought that Patrick actually so I
disagree with the internet I thought
Patrick just took on a kind of Devil's
Advocate like he was he was purposely
being stubborn to bring out the best in
you but the internet thought that he's
being stubborn not being open to your
ideas I thought the tension between
ideas
um I think a lot of the tension had to
do probably with uh Donald Trump and
Trump supporters that certainly could be
the case and people wrote to me after
people wrote To Me the full gamut of
everything you can imagine from this was
your best thing you've ever done in
public to you got humiliated and your
mother should have aborted you okay so
every and everything in between so you
know take your pick but
um the most interesting feedback I got
was from people who asked me after was
it incredibly tense and awkward and
because it seemed so combative and I
think for I'm so used to those types of
tensions in the discussions that I have
that it's very comfortable to me it's
not like afterwards it's it's there's a
grudge or it's tense or whatever the
case may be I'm very comfortable just I
I disagree with people and that's it so
I did not find anything that happened
inappropriate I disagreed with a lot of
the things he said certainly
uh so you've also spoken to Michael
Knowles
um I think about the idea of what is a
woman I do
can you speak broadly about your
conversation with the people you
disagree with
uh you know some of the cases it feels
like it's gone wrong the conversations
have gone wrong yeah yeah I mean I think
there's a couple different things and
I'm the first to tell you that
depending on who I'm talking to I go in
with a different attitude about how
quote seriously I'm taking it in the
sense of whether I think it's going to
be a deep policy discussion versus
whether it's going to be more of a
performance for an audience that is
expecting a certain thing and I think
there's different types of shows when I
was interviewed by this guy Jesse Lee
Peterson in Los Angeles it's very
different for example than when I'm
talking to Patrick Bett David just to
give two two examples I I think
the reason I stopped doing the Michael
Knowles show was the number of threats I
would get after the fact that's really
the reason I was glad to engage with him
to the extent that the interviews were
interesting and you know we could
organize it reasonably efficiently
um but the reason I stepped away was
sort of the aftermath but I did find him
to be someone who was abundantly clear
about his View and where he comes from
and while I could not possibly disagree
more with him in terms of politics and
culture and our backgrounds everything
is just so so different I found it easy
to engage in the conversation just
because of how upfront and clear he was
about what his beliefs were
but the number of threats yeah much yeah
it was just too much and this um you
know I don't know if how much you saw
about this recent Twitter dust up I was
involved in that peaked with Donald
Trump Jr tweeting about me and then that
then declining from there let's talk
through it I didn't see it okay I have
to understand like uh the way you study
Shakespeare I have to study your Twitter
I have to understand so much how much of
his sarcasm it's mostly sarcasm I mean
here's the thing and I know that there
are people who will say David you're
dealing with such serious issues it's
really not okay not to take everything
you do completely seriously but my view
is it's so incredible that I've between
chance and timing and so different
things falling into a position where
this is what I do professionally and
it's a career and it's financially
sustainable and all these different
things I don't want to end up taking
myself too seriously because I recognize
the timing and luck and all of these
other things and this could have gone a
completely different way so my approach
to a lot of this is let's not take
ourselves too seriously and in
particular on Twitter a platform that
you know the degree to which it should
be taken very seriously maybe has
changed over time I'm always sort of
thinking a little bit tongue-in-cheek on
Twitter so what happened with uh Donald
Trump Jr so or the full Arc of it yeah
to make give you a one minute Arc and
then we can pick whichever parts we want
after
a mass shooting now you might say
there's like two or three a day you're
correct after the Nashville mass
shooting at a Christian School
I tweeted
snarkily tongue-in-cheek to point that
thoughts and prayers not only aren't
particularly useful after a shooting
they also don't prevent shootings that
there's some confusion about how there
would be a shooting at a Christian
School given that it is a place where
prayer is taking place I think I I you
know jokingly said something like were
they not praying enough for correctly in
my deep journalistic Integrity you have
it I have yourself this is this is the
only display of journalistic
I will show today okay and I have a
couple of responses beautiful and you
deleted the Tweet since then which I
regret oh interesting we can talk about
that I would love to because it's such a
yeah interesting decision
uh because when you tweet something one
of the things I've also learned is you
don't often understand
how it's going to be read it's going to
be analyzed like I mentioned Shakespeare
like there's certain the use of certain
words that you regret saying in a
certain kind of way maybe just because
it wasn't as eloquent as as powerful it
didn't actually convey the thing um or
it's a distraction to the main message
all that kind of stuff okay the actual
tweet is very surprising that there
would be a mass shooting at a Christian
School given that lack of prayer is
often blamed for these horrible events
is it possible they weren't praying
enough or correctly despite being a
Christian School
and um
a lot of people quote retweeted that
which I'm assuming was uh
the criticism so Colin Wright wrote I
used to consider you a reasonable
Progressive but you clearly devolved
into partisan hackery I'm an atheist it
cannot begin to Fathom using the murder
of children and adults at a Christian
school as an opportunity to dunk on the
concept of prayer and you responded I'm
dunking on the people who send thoughts
and prayers and do nothing else and the
shootings continue okay I'm sure there's
a lot of other interactions there's a
few other hundred thousand interactions
so the do you want the ark leading to
this yeah so so basically it's going to
display do you know what time of day I
tweeted the original one I feel like it
was in the afternoon or evening of on a
Monday
3 42 pm
on 27th March 27th which was a Monday
okay so basically I tweet that and then
I finish the day and so you tweet and
then you go on with your day I might
have looked once at Twitter and it had 2
000 likes and a few people saying ah
this might have missed the mark but it's
sort of like it's one of my 20 000
tweets I don't know
I wake up the next morning my baby
daughter did not sleep till 7 30 the way
I would like so she's up at 6am and I
get up and I'm just there starting to
make breakfast and I glance at my phone
and I'm starting to this was when
verified meant a different thing than it
means now I'm seeing all these verified
accounts that are you know quote
tweeting it and demanding a retraction
and whatever and I go oh okay this looks
like it's getting looks like it's
getting some attention
um I then continue about my day around
noon I hear from my dad that he got a
hundred messages from you should have
aborted your son to we're gonna find all
of you to whatever else my dad has no
idea what's going on he's like I don't
know what this is but I have a hundred
DMs
to everything else you can imagine and
I start to get emails about you know we
you know your Jewish faith this and that
and the other thing and so at that point
to me I thought this is just going to
get worse and worse and worse and so I
deleted the tweet and I really regret
doing that because over the 48 hours
that followed yes the attacks escalated
it went through Candace Owens and then
at foxnews.com Newsmax kind of peaking
with with Donald Trump Jr and it was
horrible I mean
thousands and thousands of the okay but
once I told my audience about what
happened I got thousands of messages
from people saying David only someone
who doesn't know you and is determined
to interpret this in the worst possible
Faith would think you're blaming kids
who died for getting shot of course you
weren't doing that I wish you hadn't
deleted it so that it would still be up
and you would now see the tide kind of
turning on it this was not a fun three
days regardless but I do regret having
deleted it because
um it was a pan I wanted to do the
quickest thing I thought I could to get
people to stop trying to find family
members and send them threats and so
around noon that's what I did and the
truth is the threats didn't stop anyway
because everybody had screenshotted it
and I do wish I'd left it up
and is there some degree
maybe stepping outside yourself do you
regret tweeting that in that it feeds
the mockery engine
that that fuels Twitter so like does
that tweet really represent what you
believe
it absolutely represents the disgust
with a politics that includes saying we
can't touch guns we just we can't but
we're willing to point to mental health
or say we need more prayer in schools or
whatever one thousand percent it
represents that view
is it the type of snark and sarcasm that
I would use if given an hour to discuss
the topic rather than whatever the
number of characters is now on Twitter
no definitely not and so I am very
cognizant of the fact that it was
unnecessarily provocative How It Was
Written
I I think I asked similar question to
Ben Shapiro do you worry that this style
of presentation can turn you from being
um you know a deeply thoughtful
objective political thinker to somebody
who's just a partisan
hack or partisan uh what's a good word
talking head do you mean with regard to
Twitter or the format of my show in
general it was so Twitter for now let's
start with Twitter for now and can you
Silo your
style of communication on Twitter from
being a virus that affects your mind
right
I don't have deep thoughts about the
Twitter component Beyond I think across
all sorts of disciplines this is not the
best way to most effectively solve
problems
and figure out solutions to complex
issues you talk about Twitter now right
now I'm talking about Twitter yes that
being said I think all of us to some
degree have to adapt our content to the
platform that we're using in the same
way that what I post to YouTube is
different than what I post to tick tock
would I post to Twitter is also
different do I think Twitter has been an
unmitigated good for society no
um have I chosen to step into Twitter as
one of the ways in which I get my
message out with the good and the bad
yes and I think that there is a deep
conversation to be had there
I think zooming out a little bit in
terms of what I do and I was hoping this
would come up because I think it's
really interesting
I will often get emails from people who
say two things I will get the you would
have such a bigger audience if you did X
Type emails and usually they are plays
to sensationalism
salacious and titillating content more
pop culture Stuff
Etc
on the other hand it's folks who say
listen what you're doing really isn't as
serious as it could be and it seems like
you could do something more serious and
you should consider doing
deep Dives you know once it was do a
deep dive into Calvin Coolidge and I was
like nobody will watch that so there
it's not by accident that my show is the
way it is right in an hour I'm thinking
of all the platforms I'm on and I'm
saying okay
I want to do a relatively Deep dive on
the federal budget and I want to talk
about some of the
um political tomfoolery going on within
the post office and I'm going to do a
segment about the wacky rally where
Trump said crazy things and made up
three words and said he endorsed a
candidate who's named it right I'm
crafting that in total to find a balance
between let's build this audience as
much as I can in order to have a bigger
base to get my message out there and
include the more serious stuff with the
hope that there's a little bit of
something for everyone and I'm finding a
balance between those two sides of the
spectrum it's a deliberate thing and I'm
aware that if I were producing my show
50 years ago the balance would probably
be different and it would probably
change again if we didn't if the show
was Audio Only rather than having all
these video platforms it would also be
different but it's a decision that's
proactively made to try to get the best
and most out of the hour that I'm
creating every day well it just feels
like there's an entire machine
fed by Twitter and journalism that wants
to divide people
and the drama of that division
highlighting the the partisan division
the drama of that division feels like
it's a tension with objective clear
thinking sometimes
and so that's the
I worry that there's a drug to it
there's too much fun to mock
ridiculous people
on on a uh on the other side I think
you're right about that and
the fact that that is true
to me supports I've talked with my
audience about you know like the old
food pyramid which I guess was like
wrong but let's imagine that there was a
pyramid that that made sense uh the
bottom bread I think uh like whole
grains maybe I don't remember it's been
a while
junk food is at the very top I'm very
open with my audience
the vast majority of what I do is the
top of that pyramid
and I tell people very openly I don't
consume a lot of the type of content I
produce
and I think it's really important to as
a base be doing critical thinking
epistemology how do we believe the
things we believe
Basics about the world
after that reading history economics
philosophy Etc
after that now we're getting into
current events I would mostly be looking
at consuming
um primary source reporting things like
Associated Press whatever I know
everybody will have a different list of
what counts there after that is when I'd
say indulge in some of the commentary
type stuff that I do
if you find that I'm thoughtful enough
to make it into that but I'm very open
and really what I try to do on my show
often is in being that at the top of the
pyramid tell people there's all this
other stuff that should be forming your
foundation that I hope you're consuming
in addition to just watching me and I'm
very open with my audience about that
what about the shape the Dynamics the
the characteristics of your audience is
there some degree to which you're
through mocking maybe Republicans that
there's a
there's a lean to that audience and then
you become captured by the audience do
you worry about the audience capture I
worry about it
I'm relatively comfortable that it's not
shaping the program to a great degree
in the sense that at this point I have a
pretty good sense of the things I can
say that will upset what I might call my
core audience you know one of the
interesting things just to briefly go
back to the Twitter thing was those
people who were furious with me on
Twitter and they contacted my
advertisers and some advertisers dropped
me and on and on and on none of them are
actually in my audience none of them are
regular consumers of my audience they
were kind of weaponized Against Me by
people who said hey look at this the
people who follow Candace Owens on
Twitter other than for their kind of
shock value they're not in my audience
and with my core audience I know there
are things I can talk about that will
generate
um
displeasure I guess you could say with
my audience sometimes when I touch the
israeli-palestinian conflict that will
happen
sometimes on vaccines there's a portion
of my audience that is more generally
skeptical of vaccines
um sometimes on some foreign policy uh
issues or you know I I'm not a big fan
of Marianne Williamson nor Bobby Kennedy
Junior's challenges to Joe Biden not
because I love Joe Biden but because I
don't consider them to be the most
serious Challengers I know there's
people in my audience who don't like
that they get they get mad at me about
that and I'm totally okay with that uh
and that tension with with my core
audience so in that sense I don't feel
as though I've had that audience capture
take place but I know it can happen and
I'm very open to to being told ways in
which it may be happening without me
noticing uh so I've uh made a call for
questions on Reddit for this
conversation
there's a lot of good questions that
I'll probably bring up but one of them
was about Marianne Williamson
um asking why David thinks she is a
garbage candidate which of course I've
never said but perhaps you have more
eloquently criticized so let's let's go
there sure to the 2024 election okay
so Biden Joe Biden officially announced
that he's running again Donald Trump
officially announced that he's running
again
in if that's the matchup who do you
think wins
if the election's held today
I think Biden
why well first of all I believe he won
last time
and if I start with the results from
2020 and I think to myself what has
happened since then that would push or
pull voters one way or the other
I have a hard time making a case that
Trump is in a better position today than
he was in November of 2020.
so that's kind of my starting point
which is it's a rematch of an election
with a known outcome
what has changed
and I can't make a case for
circumstances having changed in Trump's
favor to give a couple of state level
examples Florida seems to be kind of
moving more to the Republican side since
2020 but Trump won that state already in
2020 so it wouldn't really change the
outcome Arizona was close I think
Arizona has moved to the left since 2020
so I don't see Trump taking that one
Wisconsin I think the same sort of thing
applies so being very like practical
that would be kind of the start of my
reasoning
do you think Joe Biden is a better
candidate now than he was
in 2020.
I think
he's a worse candidate
this is going to sound ageist but I
think he's a worse candidate in that
he's even older and there already seems
to be an appetite for younger candidates
particularly on the Democratic voting
side so he's going to be four years
older and in a sense that could be a
liability
however he also is going to have four
years of accomplishments now you might
not like the things he's done in which
case that would hurt him but he has
started to accumulate
um not insignificant number of
accomplishments some of the big things
that are known inflation reduction act
and covet stimulus you know but also
less well-known things like a bunch of
little tweaks to Health Care a bunch of
little tweaks to student lending there's
been a lot of little things
um at the macro level I don't actually
think Joe Biden has that much to do with
this the same way I didn't credit or
attack Trump for a lot of the
macroeconomic stuff but inflation has
started to come down significantly the
stock market's quite steady these sort
of things I think looking historically
it's a pretty okay environment for Joe
Biden with the exception that he was
already the oldest president to be
inaugurated in 2021 and he would beat
his own record in January of 2025 and I
just don't know how voters are going to
see that
so in terms of just a public human being
how would you compare Trump and Biden so
if I were to give criticism towards
trump it would be that he's chaotic
maybe to the point of being
disrespectful to a lot of different
groups to a lot of different ideas to a
lot of different nations and leaders and
all that kind of stuff and then the
criticism towards Biden would be that
he
'd
maybe perhaps because of age or any
other kind of cognitive capabilities is
not really there mentally as a
you know in the way that perhaps you
could say like Barack Obama was there
just mentally being able to handle all
kinds of aspects of being a public
representative of a Nation to the world
and to the people of that Nation so
which uh in the competition of
Personality flaws which do you think is
more powerful you've laid out
fair and I believe accurate assessments
of elements of both of those uh men yeah
you haven't weighed in on to what degree
you value each of those assessments
which is where I think the the kind of
meat of this question really is
um I don't see and I know that you know
Biden's going to get us into World War
III World War Three that doesn't seem to
be happening
um I don't see
the Biden deficits you listed which I
agree with you on I don't see them as
um
dangerous or threatening to the standing
of the United States
in this kind of environment with our
Western traditional Western allies and
geopolitics Etc in the way that the sort
of unhinged personality of trump
combined with his lack of knowledge
about most issues is a threat so for me
if those two are the candidates
Biden would be my choice now are there
people I would rather see on the
Democratic side yes if I knew the
president would be a republican can I
think of better options than Trump
absolutely you know I think it's it's so
funny when in 2012 it was Obama versus
Romney the difference seemed so
significant between them thinking back
I'm sure I would disagree with Mitt
Romney about tax rates and his views on
LGBT or I'm sure I I know are different
than mine but it seems without looking
at him with rose-colored glasses so
comparatively benign given the the four
years of trump so that's kind of where I
come down even uh McCain and Obama the
the differences seemed quite drastic
yeah McCain was interesting because
Palin as his running mate opened the
door to the sort of cartoonish stuff
that we've started to see on the
Republican side Palin Trump Marjorie
Taylor green it started going in that
direction which has made the party a bit
of a joke a aside from what you believe
the tax rate would be right you can say
taxes are too high but Jewish space
lasers come on you know so uh but but I
I agree with you on McCain also so go
back to the political terms we talked
about what where in that Spectrum do you
place yourself today
um what which of the label do you think
captures your political views
Progressive Social Democrat
um which which again is a capitalist I
own my own business I pay the taxes I'm
legally required to pay and not a penny
more and you know all those things
that's where I place myself would you
please yourself to the left of Joe Biden
yes yes
where does the AOC fit into that
it's a good question what do you think
about AOC as a candidate do you think
she eventually runs
I think that if she doesn't run into
some kind of Scandal and I don't mean
scandal in the sense of some personal
impropriety that you know but I mean
some kind of major political problem it
seems that she has the staying power to
be an American elected politics for a
long time whether she would even want to
be president versus maybe going to the
senate or being Governor or whatever the
case may be I have no idea what her
Ambitions are in that sense but
certainly like policy aside she has this
combination of charisma
likability to some
but also something about her personality
that angers the people who don't like
her in a way that only fuels her sort of
uh presence which I think applies to
Trump as well
um that I do think that she has the
potential to be to have significant
staying power in American politics
president I don't know do you think
that's the future of uh
political elections and politics in
general is people who are able to
skillfully piss off the other side like
AOC and Trump did I think it's an aspect
of it I think it's also understanding
how to communicate policy ideas
Trump you know I have things I can
praise Trump about if we want to get to
that segment at some point you let me
know when that is but I I do think that
there are some things Trump is very good
at and this is why it's very hard for me
to believe that Ron DeSantis has what it
takes to actually fight Trump in a
national primary and
um one of those things is Trump has a
even though he often says very strange
things that if you transcribe them you
go that's what language is that that
doesn't make any sense whatsoever in the
moment the way he relates to
um adversaries on stage Etc is very good
in that he is very much aware of how it
is going to be seen by the audience and
so that's why a lot of times it's more
about doesn't matter that a word salad
came out of his mouth how he immediately
responded and related to the person
who's very good so I think that knowing
how to be good when Clips are shared all
the time often out of context is
extraordinarily important knowing how to
use social media which every election
cycle that means some nothing different
but understanding how to use social
media very important those things are
absolutely
so important and whether you're able to
do a deep dive on the deficit it's
certainly useful but I would say it's a
bad thing it's becoming less important
in terms of figuring out who we want to
represent us so just lingering on the
AOC and then maybe let's throw in Bernie
Sanders on that yeah
so where do you place yourself and how
do you do the layout of the land of
Bernie Sanders AOC Joe Biden and uh
David backman my instinct is and the the
I'm going to answer it the thing that
makes this tough is
Bernie says I'm he's a Democratic
Socialist he ran as a Social Democrat he
didn't run on anything that was really
socialism right so I'm going by their
public facing platforms I've been
listening to him for many many years and
uh all the way back to the Thom Hartmann
Show and I think using the terms as
you've been using them yeah he has I
don't think ever been a Democratic
Socialist I haven't heard him speak
about socialism
I think I've heard him speak about
social programs and the value of social
programs yeah throughout the history of
the United States and their and how
they've been beneficial my understanding
is very similar to yours although there
may be stuff from the 70s where he
really was talking about those [__] in
the 70s yeah yeah you and I even who
weren't around we were doing stuff I
feel like we did yeah my sense would be
you know Biden is like Center left and
then I'm to the left of that
but maybe just inside of where AOC and
Bernie are very very similar to Bernie I
mean I I identify with a lot of Bernie's
ideas
maybe their implementation I'm more
flexible on I'll give you one example
Medicare for all
one way of trying to get health care to
everybody which Bernie's very big on is
you take the current Medicare program
you just eliminate the age limit make it
available to everybody pay for it
through taxation interesting however I'm
open to other models if they get
everybody health care that is
good quality and affordable Singapore
has an interesting model Germany has an
interesting model I am I am more
agnostic about how we do it than just
saying let's expand Medicare whether
that puts me to the right of of Bernie I
don't I don't know but I'm not like
exactly right there on it has to be
Medicare for all yeah that's more of uh
that's more just flexibility versus
dogmatism so I don't know if that puts
you to the left or to the right I don't
either what do you think about the
who could term manipulation or the
corruption in the DNC that
perhaps tip the scales against Bernie in
the election do you think there was that
2016 or 2020
[Laughter]
uh both I would say uh in different the
Dynamics there were different with
Hillary Clinton and um like the pressure
from Hillary Clinton as a candidate and
so on yeah what I mean was there why
didn't Bernie win I guess is one one way
to ask okay
I think there's a couple things here
first the DNC I'm not a Democrat just
your audience may not know I'm just a
independent yeah I mostly vote for
candidates that end up being Democrats
in local elections often there's no
party designation so okay I'm obviously
on the left I'm not denying that but the
Democratic party is as an institution
has never really been interesting to me
you're still a rebel that resists
belonging to any institution exactly
right exactly right and whether it
matters I I don't know
um the DNC and the RNC really are
organizations that to some degree exist
to justify their own existence because
if they were no longer necessary
they would go away and so they have to
assert their value and their importance
they do this in a number of different
ways organizing the way that the nominee
is chosen the convention uh working with
States on everything from redistricting
to whatever else the case may be setting
the order of primaries and having some
involved and how that's all going to
happen and also coordinating behind the
scenes uh I guess they would describe it
as making sure our candidates don't get
in each other's ways we might see it and
say they're picking the the winner
there's nothing illegal about them being
involved in picking the winner but we
might say it's not in people's interests
I think the 2020 primary was really
interesting Bernie supporter myself
I started telling my audience after
a couple primaries and even before based
on polling and different things I see a
real uphill battle here for Bernie
and it's really important people in my
audience are not the average you know
union worker in Michigan who is mostly
working and raising a family and then
goes to vote on primary day and goes to
vote on Election Day if you spend a lot
of time on Reddit and Twitter you're
going to have an inflated sense of
Bernie's popularity within the
Democratic Party
that was my sense
and to some degree
we saw that in certain States I don't
have the exact primary order and results
in front of me or in my head but the big
turning point was South Carolina
South Carolina was when Joe Biden won
and won handily
understood to be because of the larger
African-American population in South
Carolina
and right around that exact same time I
actually don't remember now whether it
was the day after or the day before some
of the smaller Democratic candidates
smaller in terms of support got out and
said I'm endorsing Joe Biden and to some
degree of course it was all organized
and timed to help Joe Biden there's no
doubt about that this is what the DNC
does it's hard for me to be mad at the
DNC because this is sort of like if if
we believed they were there to be
unbiased Arbiters and to stay as much on
the side as possible it would make sense
to be furious that they've gone against
their stated you know kind of mandate
but we know that the DNC
negotiates and is it working behind the
scenes and has a favorite that favorite
was Hillary in 2016 2020. so I share the
frustration about the power that the DNC
has but for people who were saying they
did something illegal or whatever else
the case may be that that doesn't seem
to be the case but this is part of why I
mean I would love there not to be this
duopoly of Republicans and Democrats and
there's probably four major changes that
have to happen in order to make that a
reality but I share the frustration of
folks while recognizing
that Reddit was not accurately
representing Bernie's level of
popularity still I wish that the bias
wasn't towards the uh what could be
negatively termed a deep State towards
the bureaucracy towards the momentum of
the past which I think Joe Biden kind of
represents uh versus new ideas which is
funny to say that Bernie Sanders somehow
represents new ideas because he's also
an older gentleman well it's a frame
it's a lot of Framing and the other
aspect to that is on paper
Joe Biden's platform was arguably the
most Progressive of any Democratic
candidate who won the nomination now of
course there were people who challenged
the nominations who were to Joe Biden's
left a lot of this is perspective and it
it you know that's how you end up saying
the guy who's a couple years older than
Biden is actually the guy with the fresh
perspective which is interesting because
I don't disagree with you
yeah and you also have to say the
perspective doesn't always align with
the policies you're right and you know
the actual policies of Joe Biden are
different than the maybe the perception
of Joe Biden or what he ran on I mean
just two examples I would give are
during his campaign he played up a
little bit his interest in doing student
loan forgiveness and something on
cannabis I never bought it I told my
audience I think he's saying this stuff
because this is the way the tide is kind
of the wind is blowing and he's being
advised to say this stuff I don't think
he's going to do very much on either of
these things he did actually do some
student loan stuff but that would be two
examples I think
okay let's go to the
uh something you alluded to which is the
pros and cons of a particular candidate
well what to you as a Critic of trump
what do you are
um the pros the strengths of uh Donald
Trump and which you are his biggest
weaknesses the strengths of trump
see how I can frame though in a way that
is both accurate and and accurately
assesses my my feeling about it and can
be taken out of context most masterfully
through the clipping process yes Trump's
strengths are mostly superficial and in
terms of presentation
Trump was able to I I call it a grift
some on the right say he's just so good
at relating to different types of people
Trump as a rich guy from New York City
was able to convince people that he
spent most of his life trying to be kept
isolated from that he had their best
interests in mind that he knew why they
weren't doing well in the 2016 economy
and that he had solutions that he was
going to bring forward the truth is
he never really liked those people and
as soon as they weren't useful to him
for a brief period of time he you know
that that love affair with his followers
stopped and then now it's back then he
needs them again
he didn't really understand the causes
of the problems that those folks were
experiencing and his Solutions were
laughable right like Jared was going to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
in year one he was going to replace
Obamacare in 2017 things that were never
going anywhere anywhere but what he did
really well was he put up a united front
of I know what is ailing you
I know how to fix it and I know how to
fix it I guess because he's a
businessman and he's been Above The Fray
of politics for so long knowing how to
use political donations to his Advantage
he called that smart Etc I think that's
his greatest strength why do you say
that the the the the the Jared plan for
Israel Palestine and the plan for health
care to improve Obamacare why why do you
say that's laughable well only someone I
would include the North Korea plan as
well which I'm glad to talk about only
someone who doesn't know anything about
the size and scope of these issues could
so arrogantly say that they could solve
them in that way and on that time frame
I'm all for optimism and and bringing a
new face to things absolutely without a
doubt but you know a wall with Mexico
that Mexico will pay for at the end of
my first term
I I know there are people who believed
it because they would call into my show
and say I'm voting for Trump because of
it but it's hard to believe that anybody
serious would fall for that unless you
were deliberately wanting to just
believe whatever was being fed to you or
you just hadn't ever thought about these
issues before the health care plan you
know in 2017 they proposed one would
have led to 24 million or so people
ending up without Health Care didn't go
anywhere because it was so terrible and
then in August of 2020 Trump said in in
two weeks I'm gonna finally have my
health care proposal it's 2023. we we
still never got it you know with all of
these things when you think them through
it was just sort of arrogance and I get
the perspective of I want optimism and I
liked that optimism it worked I mean
Fair a lot of people saw it and liked it
as someone who followed a lot of those
those issues closely
they seemed of course like impossible
promises well it's a double-edged sword
says they're pushed back a little bit if
you look at the things I have
um a little bit more knowledge about
which is the space of artificial
intelligence
there's a company called deepmind and
it's a company called open AI
that will laugh to have for a long time
when they were talking about that
they're going to solve intelligence
and now they've made especially Deep
Mind and our most recently open AI with
GPT they've made progress that most of
that Community would not have imagined
to be able to make everything from alpha
gold beating the wheelchair uh world go
Champion just all the different steps
and progress that I can get into were
surprised everybody and they are
legitimately
uh fearlessly pursuing uh the task of
solving intelligence the other aspect he
gets a lot of criticism now but another
example is Elon Musk
uh in I can say a lot of things like
SpaceX so commercial space flight he was
laughed at for a long time that that's
possible uh same thing with autopilot in
Tesla autonomous vehicles his approach
was harshly criticized by all the
experts and I still criticized to this
day deeply criticized and I as a person
that I believe objectively can look at
the progress of autopilot as a
semi-autonomous vehicle system has been
incredibly surprising so the reason I
mention that is sometimes it feels like
you need the guy or the gal who's who
makes those uh Preposterous ambitious
statements like we're going to solve
Health Care this year
like and then and then there's experts
like yourself that are looking thinking
have you read anything about the history
of the Israel Palestine is a good is it
a good example of that do you know
there's a history there do you realize
how complicated how many people have
tried how many people have failed how
many millions of people hate each other
in this in this little uh place in this
in this land that like sometimes the
expertise can really weigh you down so
it's sort of to push back sometimes you
have to have the almost be naive and
stupid and just rush in with an optimism
in order to actually make some progress
I agree with you 100 I think it's
interesting that all of the examples you
gave of of successes are from the
technology space
not from politics which I mean listen I
would love to be able to make Headway on
some of these issues more quickly
without a doubt I do think at some point
though when it comes down to voting and
saying one of these people is going to
be ostensibly in charge for four years
through all of the Departments and
secretaries and choices that they make
we we do want to apply some level of
realism with the with the understanding
that your examples are from the tech
space and they're good examples there's
there's no question about it one thing
I'll add to this I recently read Bradley
Hope's new book about North Korea and
it's really about an activist
um who doesn't even really matter but
the in the background of the book
it's written much of what is written
about happens during the Trump era and
when Trump did the first and then the
second
um I guess you'd call them Summits with
Kim Jong-un and it actually did seem
like to some degree Trump's we're gonna
handle this like I do a business deal
approach to Kim Jong-un
in some sense it actually was logical
because of Kim Jong-un and the way that
it was so ego driven and they both as
sort of authoritarians strong men types
to different degrees wanted that there
was actually a kernel where I actually
thought as I read it Trump's initial
idea wasn't crazy the problem was he
knew nothing about the backstory of the
relationship he fell for all sorts of
lies from Kim Jong-un and he made offers
that didn't make any sense to me it fell
apart fine but that's an example where I
think Trump's personality was not
actually at its base the the problem
when it came to North Korea well there's
other things of this nature that could
go and some people argue goes into the
strengths and pros of Donald Trump for
China for example Terrace and China
can you make the case that there's some
positive outcomes of the way Donald
Trump
acted with China it's really tough and
I'll give you a couple okay then also
cons I'll give you it's tough to make so
the China thing is really so just um
very recently to when we're recording
this Trump was on Fox News interviewed
by a guy named Mark Levin and Trump
proposed a new I call it a conspiracy
theory maybe it will strike you with
something different about China covid
and tariffs and Trump's suggestion was
that the tariffs cost China so much
money China sent the U.S so much money
in tariffs
that they released covid as punishment
now there's a couple problems with that
one American companies pay the tariffs
Trump still doesn't seem to know this
Trump seems to believe that when he puts
a tariff on Chinese Imports
someone in China is cutting a check to
the United States
American companies buy the stuff from
China and then American companies cut a
check to the United States for the
Tariff
Trump doesn't seem to get that but it
still has this thing to the Chinese
economy you can make the argument that
if there is a suitable alternative
domestically or from a different country
that it will reduce Imports but but it
didn't happen and we actually have
reports now that the tariffs on China
cost about a quarter million American
jobs
the other problem with that idea is
China created and released the virus in
order to hurt you
but as of today
5.7 of the 6.8 million deaths were in
other countries it's a very indirect way
you're mostly killing people in other
countries to hurt Trump maybe there was
a this is the sort of thing where when I
think about how Trump dealt with China
it's very scary because given another
four years who who knows what he might
do if he still doesn't understand how
tariffs work so geopolitics operates
in complicated ways with carrots and
sticks and Henry Kissinger has written
quite a lot about this and in some sense
the positive aspect here that uh Donald
Trump is willing to take big risks in uh
in the game of geopolitics with this uh
giant superpower that is China and a lot
of others are too afraid
too afraid to call them out to come to
the table and criticize
I certainly think that's an argument
that can be made my question would be
what tangible positive outcomes did it
lead to and it's tough to identify any
but I think it's a great thing I mean
listen
one of the things you're kind of getting
at maybe indirectly is that there's been
this sense that politics has been done
very similarly for a long time and even
between Democrats and Republicans
still even with some policy differences
there's still the kind of feeling that
it's disconnected folks in DC mostly
dealing with issues that don't directly
affect look I get that I'm with you on
that I think the question as to whether
Trump's Bluster was positive rather than
extraordinarily humiliating in many ways
I just come down on it was an absolute
and total humiliation but I understand
that you can recognize Trump doesn't
know a lot of stuff but his attitude was
refreshing in some way that's a
reasonable position for someone to take
I disagree with it but I understand it
but it's trying and failing better than
not trying
this goes well beyond politics you know
Wayne Gretzky is weighed in about this
Michael Jordan is waiting I mean this is
uh yeah is it better to have tried and
failed than never is it better to have
loved and lost than never to have loved
I don't know I mean listen we live
through four years of trump we know what
that four-year term was like
and it's very hard for me to say that
the things he tried
were were overwhelmingly reasonable but
I get the point you're trying to make
and I appreciate it and and it's if we
don't do any of it then where do we end
up sure we know where we ended up with
with Trump and it was pretty
embarrassing
uh okay let's linger uh on some more
strengths we didn't start any new Wars
we didn't search something to that yeah
that's it's it's interesting there's a
few different approaches uh to dealing
with that
um first it's really important to
remember that the Counterpoint to that
from the folks who like to say that was
that Hillary Clinton was going to start
three Wars sometimes they say four Wars
sometimes they say five Wars okay
um the geopolitical situation during the
four years that Trump was in office I
don't know that they obviously lent
themselves to Wars that Trump just
barely was able to keep us out of I
think the Russia thing is interesting
because now it's very popular to go back
and say you know the reason Putin didn't
do the Ukraine thing when Trump really
right and to somehow give Trump credit
for that there's a Counterpoint to it
which is Putin under Trump particularly
if Trump got four more years would have
been able to maybe consolidate power in
other ways because of his relationship
with Trump I'm not coming down on one
side or the other it's not my area
expertise but it's not the open shut
slam dunk that you know Trump likes to
say it is Putin didn't invade because he
knew I would crush him and okay so it's
not obvious to me that there were
imminently Wars that would have started
during that time that being said
um you know for all the criticism of
Obama during Crimea
Trump seemed to just kind of forget
about that after all the criticism and
say I'm not actually going to do
anything about that and so there's there
are foreign policy uh criticisms that
that could be made but it is true no new
wars were started under Trump and I I
like that I don't like Wars what do you
think about his handling of kovid
can you say what are the pros and cons
of his handling of coven the con for him
is he'd be president right now if he had
handled it differently
I think it's abundantly clear
um early on and there's now a lot of
really good reporting about the
conversations he was having with Jared
Kushner and others
he became convinced either because of
things he was being told or because he
decided this is the way it's going to be
this is going to go away fine it's in
China okay it's in China in Italy okay
we have 15 cases but it'll soon be zero
will be open by Easter of 2020.
none of it happened
if he had handled it in the following
way and I've said this to Rogan and I've
said this to Patrick David and they tend
to all see my side of this if Trump had
said listen
we don't know how bad this is going to
be but I care too much about the
American people to take a shot
so it's not going to be two weeks it's
going to be a little bit but I need your
help we're going to bring everybody
together I don't care if you're a
democrat or a republican we're going to
have Maga masks and you could have kept
50 cents on the dollar to pay off stormy
or whoever right but it would have been
I think he wins re-election because the
perception was and reality is aversion
of that the perception was that he was
way too Cavalier about it early on uh
people died who didn't need to die
and
I think that it was arguably
the one area where he could have all but
guaranteed that he was going to get
himself reelected well to push back on
that I mean because you mentioned sort
of masks and lockdowns kind of a
solution to covid I didn't mention
lockdowns but I'm glad to talk about
politics like there's several solutions
to a pandemic yeah broadly speaking and
one of them is a vaccine and so you
didn't mention that he'd Fast Track the
development he his administration fast
tracked the development of the vaccine
which surprising he didn't really take
much credit for I think he did I think
he tried there's a couple there's a lot
there well to me it seems like
you could make the case
with the Trump hand gestures that his
decisions for fast tracking the
development of the vaccine saved tens of
millions of lives you can make you he
could in the trumpian way make that case
so couple different things I know you
don't necessarily follow Trump's rallies
as closely as I do and I'm jealous of
you for that but
um he did Tout The vaccine stuff hugely
for a while
until his audience turned against him
and then he had to draw this line where
he was going I made the vaccines which
none of you have to take by the way
Freedom you don't have to take them but
it's fantastic and nobody else could
have done it but don't worry nobody's
gonna make you take the vaccine and he
actually got booed at a couple of his
own rallies when talking about the
vaccines but let's back up a little bit
fast tracking my understanding of what
he did is he did what any president in
his situation would do and what many
world leaders elsewhere did as well
which is he agreed to a pre-purchase
supply of vaccine in order to provide
money to pharmaceutical companies to
scale up the manufacturing which is
absolutely fine
but he wants one of the stories he tells
is it usually takes 12 years to develop
a vaccine we did it in my nine months
thanks to me
Decades of mRNA technology being
developed created the platform in which
you can make a particular vaccine in
nine months it didn't have anything to
do with Trump
he did pre-fund and say we will buy huge
supply and that provided liquidity to
the pharmaceutical companies but he also
delegated control to uh to people to
experts that enable that kind of uh fast
tracking vaccines right he was very
eager for the FDA to approve it because
he saw that there would be a political
benefit he didn't get in the way I guess
he didn't get in the way fair I think
now we're on the same page he did not
get in the way of vaccines being
developed which is good presidents and
bureaucracies have a way of getting in
the way
and I don't uh disagree with that I'm
not aware of really any governments that
got in the way I mean it seemed given
the global situation everybody with
European countries were pre-purchasing
vaccine uh African countries were who
were going to be later to receive
vaccines were partnering with the
European countries that had
pre-purchased but the most interesting
thing about all of this is Trump did
play up the vaccines for a long time
until his his crowd didn't want to hear
about it anymore which was crazy it was
sort of like he became a victim of the
monster he created to some degree one of
the effects of all this that makes you
truly sad is uh this division over the
vaccines has created distrust in science
yeah and also what makes me sad is the
scientific
leaders Anthony fauci being one of the
representatives of that Community
I would say completely dropped the ball
in what way they they spoke with
arrogance they spoke down to people they
spoke in a way that's that a great
scientist does not speak which is they
spoke with certainty
uh with without humility uh like they
have all the wisdom and ever all of us
are too dumb to understand it but
they're going to be the parent that
tells us exactly what to do versus
speaking to the immensity of the problem
the Deep core of the problem being the
uncertainty we don't know what to do the
the terrifying thing about the pandemic
we don't know anything about it as it's
happening and so you have to make
decisions you have to take risks about
well maybe you have to overreact in
order to protect the populace but it's
in the face of uncertainty they have to
do that not uh not powered empowered by
science somehow and the Deep expertise
is something like Anthony fauci uh
claims to have so like the the I just
I'm really troubled by um yeah the
distrust and science that resulted from
that and that you have to blame the
leaders I mean to the degree
leaders take responsibility and I think
Anthony fauci was the scientific leader
behind
um the American response to the pandemic
and I think he failed
uh as a as a scientist as a
representative of science
I'm less um
I don't know if interested is the right
word but the kind of the the fauci
review is less interesting to me in
terms of what comes next than the first
part you mentioned which is the distrust
in science and sometimes I'll get
voicemails or emails from people in my
audience who say that I have had to
backpedal on certain things related to
this and one of the things I tried to do
from the beginning was not speak in
certain terms
when we really didn't have complete
information so there was this period
where hydroxychloroquine was first sort
of mentioned as a possible treatment
prophylactic or or you know proactive
treatment for covid or active treatment
for covid along with a bunch of other
stuff that was Ivermectin there was
vitamin D there were all sorts of
different things and I tried to be
careful to say right now we don't have
rigorous science that tells us that some
of these things work it doesn't mean
that won't come in the future at which
point if there was something as cheap as
hydroxychloroquine that treated covet
effectively unbelievable fantastic
it's not there's no way it ever will be
determined we don't have that
information right now so it's not Super
Wise right now to go and start taking
this stuff we eventually learned like
with vitamin D having an appropriate
vitamin D level does seem to be based on
what I most recently read generally
protective and a good thing when it
comes to infections of different great
okay so that one we we figured out one
of the really difficult things is that
the quote truth about the vaccines did
change and the original again this is
all I don't pretend to be an expert but
just someone who's synthesizing the
medical data and writing about it
originally the first vaccine
related to the wild type strain did seem
to be very effective not only at
preventing death and serious illness but
also transmission
there were people then saying it doesn't
prevent transmission
over time as the variants came forward
the vaccine became less effective at
that at that point I started telling my
audience something different because as
far as I was concerned the reality on
the ground had changed in my mind that's
how science works it's not backpedaling
it's we're adjusting our beliefs to what
is taking place in the real world well
to be fair uh the scientists many of
whom are my friends virologists and
biologists they have way more humility
than people like Anthony faggio were
speaking about this or the CEO of Pfizer
who were speaking about this this is the
fundamental problem here is the way
science work is has the way science
works is there's usually a lot more
humility and a lot more transparency
about what we know what we don't know
and
um
people like Anthony fauci thought it
would be beneficial for the world if he
speaks with more certainty
but because of the political division
that formed around that that certainty
resulted in became completely
counterproductive that people didn't
trust anything about the vaccine didn't
trust any institutions there were that
contained the experts that actually knew
what they were doing and it basically
didn't trust anything that was coming
out of the mouths of scientists uh some
percent some large percent of the
population so you that made you
completely ineffective and uh
uh at scale as a society trying to
respond to a terrible pandemic and
that's where I put a lot of blame on
leaders so political leaders and
scientific leaders are the ones that
should Inspire us to all get together
and respond that that should be the case
for uh the pandemic that should be the
case in the time of War all this kind of
stuff I I generally agree with you and
for me it's really about shared blame
and there were a lot of different
reasons why that the early communication
wasn't good uh part of it was I mean
for me I prefer accuracy rather than
overconfidence I would prefer listen we
don't really know right now whether
masks do X or Y what we do know is the
supply is really limited of this type of
mask we're going to try to keep them for
the Frontline workers I love that that's
the way I want to be communicated to a
call was made to do it differently which
was to say The Masks don't actually help
yeah but the real reason is they want to
keep them for healthcare workers and
then later The Masks are what's going to
solve I'm with I'm with you 100 I think
the other layer to it is you can't
ignore the political situation at the
time if Trump had won re-election and
the vaccine distribution had taken place
while Trump was President rather than
Biden my belief is that the same number
of Democrats would have gotten
vaccinated but way more Republicans
would have as well because they were
following not science but political
leaders and when it was Biden in DC
instead of trump a lot of those people
said I don't trust the vaccine but wait
it's Trump's vaccine I thought yeah but
something about the way Biden's
Distributing it so I do think you can't
ignore that political layer I agree with
you the communication was a disaster
let me ask you about Joe Biden what are
the strengths and weaknesses of Joe
Biden weaknesses I think are some of the
things you've identified he has not seen
as
um high energy he is
um not the same Joe Biden that debated
Paul Ryan in 2012 and ran circles around
him in just an incredible debate
performance
uh he is not
inspiring in the way that someone like a
Barack Obama was to people coming up and
starting to get interested in politics I
think a lot of those are fair criticisms
I think on policy he's not interested in
a lot of the things that younger voters
are interested in I mentioned cannabis
reform I mentioned student loans so so I
think that that's a deficit for Biden I
think the upside to Biden is when it
comes to foreign policy diplomacy
high-level negotiations knowing how to
engage with allies in a productive way
it's tough to find someone with more
experience than Biden I know that there
are counterpoints to what I'm saying and
those include that was the old Biden the
new Biden doesn't have it that includes
that's just a sign of rot because he's
been around for so long nobody should be
around that long in politics perfectly
reasonable criticisms to talk about but
I do see that as one of his strengths
and he also is good at knowing when he
can work with Republicans and when he
can't
and not wasting more time than is sort
of expected for posturing reasons and I
think that that's a good thing do you
think he's actually there so in uh
day-to-day operational government given
his cognitive capabilities do you think
he is um
uh an active and practicing executive I
don't know that I can say that it's
because of what may be going on
cognitively but my sense from the people
I talk to is that he's very much
involved in the highest level
geopolitical and big domestic economic
stuff
but that a lot of the smaller issues
that presidents might or might not be in
sort of plugged into that he's not
plugged into the the details of a lot of
the the lower level stuff yeah you could
probably apply the same exact criticism
even more so towards the Donald Trump
Administration in terms of being a
practicing active uh executive who's
paying attention like for example like
Vladimir Putin is somebody
um
who loves the the role of the executive
has a huge amount of meetings has
constantly tracking information about
agriculture and all the different
subsystems of government Stalin
funny enough was also extremely good at
this so certain people just love the job
of being an executive and I'm not sure
if Donald Trump did
um and I'm not sure if uh Joe Biden in
this current state has the cognitive
capability too that's a it's a good
question it Kim jong-un's another one by
the way you know there's videos of him
uh examining a pottery you know a
factory where they make plates and
making very specific comments about how
the plates should be made I think that
in that case there's a lot of propaganda
value to it with Trump uh I think you're
probably right you know he did get
involved in the minutia of things I mean
once he pulled out a weather map and
with a sharpie drew a different
hurricane path that was more politically
convenient to him that's pretty micro
you know saying the weather channel is
wrong I see what you did there this is
okay I see what you did there he went to
Puerto Rico and he gave out paper towels
after a hurricane now he was shooting
them like free throws which didn't look
very good so he will get involved in the
micro when it's advantageous you know
what I mean but I do agree with you that
he wants to just kind of make it so
build the wall I don't know just build
it figure it out get it done
quick pause bathroom break sure yeah
you're hilarious
and just for the sake of completeness I
should mention the subreddit wood Biden
has done
there's also what Trump has done but
it's not as active and it has like this
master list of all the accomplishments
it's
um I recommend people look at it because
there's a
it's kind of rigorous and interesting
with links a list of all the things he's
done just list some of them uh restored
Daily Press briefings uh cancel the
Keystone Pipeline reverse Trump's Muslim
ban required masks on federal property
rejoins the Paris climate agreement
extends student loan payment freeze
extend eviction freeze historic stimulus
bill as you mentioned hence funding for
border wall and so on and so forth DACA
uh border strengthening of dot cover
joins the World Health Organization and
the timing of this of course is
important
yeah several historic stimulus bills
which of course you can criticize or
support
raise the minimum wage for federal
contractors and federal employees for
fifteen dollars
there's a lot there's a lot it makes you
realize
um with both Trump and Biden that
there's a bunch of small details
that matter yeah like that matter on
people's lives like actual little
policies uh Trump did a lot of stuff as
far as I heard for the military like not
big stuff but small stuff
yeah I'd be curious what you're thinking
of I mean I know one of the big things
under Trump was we're going to get trans
people out of the military
uh that's not what I was referring you
aren't referring to that uh he Trump
that tells you know Trump's hilarious
with these stories that he tells and one
of the story and you get to know them if
you if you follow him at all he tells
the story you know when I came into
office the generals came to me and they
said sir the cupboards are bare we have
no bullets and so I rebuilt the military
you know the cupboards were bare when
Obama left it and it was just terrible
but I rebuilt it and the generals I've
got the best generals they said sir it's
incredible what you were able to do you
look into it and it's like yeah that's
not really true like it is true that
there are armaments that just like on a
schedule do get replaced and that's part
of the military industrial complex but
there's nothing like special Trump
really did but these stories become
they take on like a life of their own
and it's interesting to sometimes try to
dig down and figure out like was there
any policy connected to that or is that
just a story
do you think it's possible to have a
good conversation with each of them
Donald Trump and Joe Biden in a pot in a
podcast context or in a debate context
absolutely yeah you're saying like could
I with either of them oh 100 yeah Joe
Biden too sure
yeah but can you dig into that a little
more well I mean I don't know what I
think there's maybe something implicit
in your in your question but uh this
deeper about the nature of politics and
politicians yes I think with either of
them I mean
the political differences wouldn't be an
impediment to having a good conversation
with either of them
um I think one of the things that's
really tough in my experience when
talking to elected officials is they
could be super interesting about 100
different topics but handlers decide or
try to get you to talk about something
you don't really care about and
something really narrow which doesn't
bring out your best nor their best and
that's a frustration but I think that
given an unstructured three-hour
conversation I think it would be
interesting to talk to both I mean
listen with with Biden aside from his
view on cannabis or whatever his
background and the incredible
unimaginable family tragedy that he had
in his first wife and you know multiple
kids dying and I mean it
it's just incredible you know and and
with Trump I think also you could have
an interesting conversation yeah those
the human beings or the life story yes
there that uh and they're some of the
most successful humans who have ever
lived to have uh Rose to this highest
office in interesting complex ways yes I
mean one of the things I'm troubled by
maybe you can speak to is why we're so
negative towards presidential candidates
and presidents why
it's just they go through this shitstorm
no matter who they are yeah they're like
hated like all the conspiracy theories
and just
just the Dynamics of how we talk about
them is vicious if you just look at
reply Stephen Barack Obama on Twitter
it's like
what is going on here why why because we
look at other leaders in other spaces
and we're generally positive about it
yeah there's a couple different things
there's this Dynamic which is really
unfortunate which is you ask people do
you approve of the job a particular
president is doing and very often if at
any point while they were in office they
did something you don't like people will
say I don't approve and so by its nature
what that means is just like the longer
you're in office the lower your approval
rating is going to be and very often
that's the way it works I mean there's
major events like 911 Spike George W
Bush's approval to a incredible level
then it came back down with the Iraq War
but there's this unfortunate thing that
when when people are just asked you
think Biden's doing a good job if four
months ago Biden did something on health
care that somebody didn't like even if
you like most of it a lot of people from
that point forward will say I don't
approve they might still vote for them
because they like him better than the
alternative or whatever it's it's just
the dynamic of politics and I agree it's
it's very does it have to be that way I
don't think it has to be that way but to
unwind it so many things would have to
change
I think our election system is part of
why politics is the way it is where you
have two choices and it's first past the
post and we have this electoral college
so that depending on which state you
vote in the kind of meaning and
significance of your vote is different
if you vote in Montana it's the
Republican candidates going to win and
that changes the Dynamics I think that's
part of it
um I think that
at a personal level I've experienced
this in my life a lot
we've become and by we I mean people in
the United States to some degree who
talk about this stuff we've become
uncomfortable when there is disagreement
and it bleeds over into now we can't
have a normal interpersonal relationship
anymore I'm from Argentina and in
Argentina it's really common even in my
family there are incredibly heated
political debates at the start the
middle the end of some kind of gathering
but then everybody just goes back to
like okay we disagree on some things but
that's okay and we can now go and you
know finish cooking the beef or whatever
it is that we're doing and I experienced
this even with people who come up to me
on the street and they go just earlier
today a guy came up to me and he said
RFK all the way baby talking about Bobby
Kennedy Jr and I just kind of you know I
said oh all right you know let's see
what happens
and then there was another moment where
the guy ended up standing next to me for
maybe longer than he thought and I could
tell this guy's getting so awkward
because it was an utterance he thought
that would just be on the Fly and he'd
be gone but now we're standing next to
each other waiting for our sandwiches
it's like no big deal you know it's just
oh okay you like Bobby Kennedy Jr I'm I
don't plan to vote for it's fine you
know and that's like a socio-cultural
thing I think there's lots of other
countries I've spent time in uh Italy I
have relatives in Israel were like
shouting at each other is sort of like
normal and then you just go back and
finish the me it sounds like shouting
I'm sort of exaggerating but very
animated what seemed like big
disagreements and then everybody's cool
yeah I wish it were more normal so maybe
the mechanism of going from shouting to
being cool again needs to improve
because maybe we can't solve the
shouting at each other maybe not so
maybe we need to somehow figure out the
de-escalation like making up I've had a
few uh recent fights with friends like
that yeah for politics no oh
no but political style emotionally
drenched stuff and it um
it was interesting
to go through that full process and then
make up at the end but it was it was a
process and it was a process that
required being in person right talking
through it and it was stressful the
whole the whole thing and maybe because
most of our interactions are online we
don't get a chance to do that in person
making up again I don't know but uh do
you think it's a feature or a bug of the
system that we're so we just hate each
well the powerful you mentioned the
online part I think it's if you
mentioned it earlier perfectly which is
you take
contentious political issues you create
a platform that rewards controversy and
disagreement and limits the number of
characters you can use to express
yourself you kind of throw it into a
baking dish and and you know mix the
entire thing up it's complete in total
chaos and one of the things that you
know I've talked before about all the
angry emails and threats and stuff that
I get I'm acutely aware that if I had
in-person conversations with most of
these people
the conversations would basically be
like oh we have different views about
how to solve some of the problems we're
facing we probably agree about what the
problem is
and we probably share many values but on
these particular four issues we may have
very different views
that's okay
online that's not the case
and it leads to you know the the mess
mess that we get ourselves in but I
think that it's a feature of a lot of
the systems that are being used to
disseminate information
again let me Linger on that do you
regret some of the mockery
uh and the snarky use on Twitter and
even in your show that kind of feeds
that division
I don't regret it in the sense that it's
a calculated part or a tool that I use
in addition to figuring out how to
simplify complicated Concepts and
choosing stories that I think are
underrepresented and you know it's it's
all part of like the package of what I'm
doing I recognize that my show is not
the audio visual visual version of a
peer-reviewed uh you know randomized
controlled trial about abortion views on
abortion or whatever the case like I'm
very much aware of that but I don't
regret including it as a as a tool
that I've used to build the community in
some total that I've built over the last
more than 10 years I guess I could ask
about the different trajectories you
think your show might take so
you know the dynamic you had with Donald
Trump Jr and maybe Candace Owens is the
more appropriate comparison are you okay
having that dance
for the next few years between you and
Candace Owens and just kind of the
mockery the derision that's a part of
that process and and taking part in that
you know I'm fine with it
in the sense of personally
I tolerate it well
until it crosses the line and people
pull my family in and people right so
that's the part that we set the family
stuff aside if I set that aside just in
the digital space I'm glad to mix it up
now the truth is Candace Owens has had
me blocked for years up until this
incident
she unblocked me just to tweet about
what I tweeted about I don't know the
backstory of that genuinely I have no
idea so I don't have a sense that she's
super interested in engaging with me on
that but all of these people I mean
Candace Owens is welcome on my show
anytime Don Jr's welcome on my show
anytime it's been a decade since I had
Ben Shapiro on he's welcome at any time
I'm glad to have these conversations and
I think it's an important thing and also
I wish that everybody was willing to
have the conversations in good faith
rather than as performance uh it's not
even really performance art rather than
being simply performative for an
audience that you have in terms of your
motivations do you see do you worry
about the effects of something we spoke
of spoke about offline like the YouTube
algorithm
do you are you driven by the number of
views
your videos get
are you driven by something else
so in my world I guess I would say the
number of views that any platform
generates is a metric that I can choose
how to interpret I can choose to
interpret it as I've created content
that's interesting to people
or I've created content that's really
angering people and that's why they're
showing up they don't actually like it
it's because they're angry or whatever
else the case may be but it is true that
there are algorithmic changes that can
take place there something happened in
early January that affected Us on
YouTube or there are periods on Tick
Tock where you can tell we're doing all
the same things
something has happened and then you
never usually figure out what it is so
for me it's sort of just like a general
tool to see what is the level of
interest in what I'm doing and are the
numbers so out of whack with what I
would expect that I should look into
whether something deeper is happening
has there been some change to an
algorithm or whatever the case may be I
had a debate once with someone who
accused me of using click bait to
generate views and we had a really
interesting conversation where I said
tell me really what you mean by that is
your argument that I'm using titles that
don't actually represent what's in the
video no what's in the title is in the
video I go okay so it's not that the
title is dishonest are you same saying
I'm deliberately picking titles that
will Garner a larger audience and they
said yeah that's kind of what I mean and
I said isn't that kind of what we're all
doing the alternative would be choosing
titles to generate a smaller audience
which seems like a real kind of waste of
time so
I'm trying to navigate and play the game
in a way that's comfortable but use the
metrics more as a tool than as something
to obsess over nevertheless the metrics
are
what they are and that they are able to
uh affect your psyche
it's very difficult which is why I have
a Chrome extension that hides all the
views and all that on YouTube uh for me
uh
it's difficult not to let it affect how
you think about ideas
so maybe your extensive exploration of a
particular topic like healthcare
generated very few views
it's difficult for you to still care
about Healthcare
there's some aspect of the human mind
that starts uh being affected by those
views and I think that's a really
dangerous thing mostly it's it's
um
probably beneficial because it probably
makes you a better presenter if you do
care about a topic a lot you become more
charismatic more you learn sort of in uh
Jimmy uh Mr Beast way how to present the
ideas better but it also can affect
which topics you choose to cover what
you choose to think about those topics
uh the audience capture those topics and
that's a really scary effect I'm really
worried about my own mind and that so I
run from that aggressively
one of the things that I include in My
overall approaches I don't think about
any One Clip I think about an entire
show or a week of shows or a month of
shows
and so it's less about does anyone clip
do well my view going in is I'm going to
do stuff that won't do that well but I
think it's really important to do and I
want to make it part of my show and so
when I did a clip with 10 ideas for
reducing gun violence I know that that's
not going to get 500 000 or a million
views I know it's just not going to and
the first day it'll get twelve thousand
and I'll go I don't care that's that's
fine there's there's a group of people
in my audience that values this stuff
and I want to keep doing this stuff
I'll end up surprised sometime and two
weeks later
has 150 000 views because it started
being shared great but I don't go into
it thinking these all need to be home
runs by that metric I always go in
saying I want to put out a diversity of
content including stuff that is less
titillating and salacious but is
important to do it's more researched Etc
and so that's the way I try to resist
exactly what you're talking about I
think you have to probably know yourself
like for me metrics I just like numbers
too much and for me metrics do affect me
this is why I don't pay attention at all
like I can't
um I would love to hire somebody in the
team who cares because we currently have
I don't know folks who just all of us
just don't care
um because he probably is good to care
enough to kind of just do good
thumbnails on this kind of stuff to to
pay attention but to me personally I
just find inner peace and focus if I
don't think about the numbers at all
because I find myself
um
I just remember a long time ago when I
started a podcast I I would
think that I failed
if it didn't do well like if I didn't
celebrate the person well enough I
didn't do a good job enough of a
conversation when that's not necessarily
at all what that means
it's it's hard not to this is tough
stuff I mean yeah I know exactly what
you're saying and part of it is
ah I mean it's it starts in my you have
a little bit of a different situation
than me because you're doing long-form
conversations with people and the prep
is a little bit different one of the
things in my space because I'm reacting
mostly to what's going on in the news
and then also picking topics to dive
into it a little bit more deeply is I
have very little control over the news
cycle and there is a a meta metric or a
macro metric that affects me
that will quadruple my audience and then
take 75 percent of it away which is the
seasonality of election Cycles
yeah and the first few election Cycles
it's very tough because I go it's it's
October I'm like
at this rate we're gonna have 20 million
subscribers by the next these numbers
are unbelievable and then it's January
30th the inauguration's over the debate
is about the debt ceiling and nothing's
going on and I go nobody's watching my
content this I must have I must have
forgotten to upload like something must
be wrong it's completely beyond my
control so I just and I think part of
what you're saying is I try to focus on
the things I can control
and understand those that I really have
no control over whatsoever and try not
to worry about them
and try to do the things that make you
happy at the end of the day
you mentioned RFK the guy you met what
do you think about uh some of the other
candidates outside of Joe Biden in the
in the Democratic party RFK Jr
what do you think of him as a candidate
I've met him we once had dinner and we
have a number of friends in common which
is what makes this a little more awkward
but I think his campaign is basically
sort of like a chaos candidacy to raise
awareness and maybe raise money either
for his book or his anti-vaccine
organization children's defense fund I
believe it's called I think there's some
reporting that Steve Bannon really liked
the idea of him running as a Democrat
again to just generate chaos
I don't find it super interesting I
don't find it worthy of that much
discussion uh smart guy nice guy
has been doing anti-vaccine work that I
don't find particularly inspiring so
it's not just anti-covered vaccine it's
more broader than them he's been in that
space long before the covet vaccines
yeah yeah I don't find it super
interesting well he also wrote the book
uh
the real Anthony fauci is that the name
of the book did he write that that's
interest I didn't I don't know that's
I'm not sure about that I'm aware of
that book I didn't know he wrote it I
think I did but it's been uh uh it's
been on my reading list to get uh I've
been trying to get a good balanced
reading list about uh the covet pandemic
to understand what the hell happened and
um anytime I start to try to go into
that place it's just I'm exhausted by it
well it's interesting to me that you
wouldn't wait longer before delving into
those books to have maybe a more
clear hindsight
but I think this is a pretty good time
you don't think so like this this is
uh it depends on your goals if you're
thinking of it as a historical event yes
you should probably wait longer but if
you're thinking about like understanding
what is broken about our system that we
responded so poorly
that there was so much division what is
broken about our political system that
um it didn't unite us it divided us
who's to blame there's probably a lot of
different narratives but I feel like the
more you learn about this the the better
you can understand I read um I'm just
Vladimir Putin I read like five
biographies already maybe more
um just it helps to really understand
the people involved the organizations
evolved I don't know everything from the
scientists to the political leaders
um
it felt like the blog posts and the
tweets didn't quite Captivate they
didn't quite no one of the things I read
a ton I don't read any like modern
political books so I don't read the
Memoirs of elected officials I don't
read any I just feel like I get enough
of it in my job so my reading list is
just other things it's history it's
narrative non-fiction economics
Etc and that's my bias because I'm so
overloaded with a lot of the stuff
you're talking about I haven't read any
of Obama's books I didn't read John
Bolton's book or you know I I don't read
any of that stuff although I'm sure
there there is value to be gleaned from
it
what about the other candidate that uh
according to the subreddit and as you
mentioned you've criticized it a little
bit uh Marianne Williamson do you think
what are the pros and cons of horizon
candidate
this is another area where many in my
audience really are angry with me yeah I
don't find her candidacy super
interesting I'll tell you the pros and
the cons as I see them I do think that
we have elected officials in the U.S
particularly presidents from a really
narrow range of backgrounds so it's
lawyers and uh sometimes business people
very very often lawyers I would I think
we would benefit from a much greater
diversity of backgrounds and I once said
and that would include uh people from
education people from the Science World
people with backgrounds maybe running
non-profits Etc now Marianne Williamson
did I guess at one point run some kind
of small non-profit and some in my
audience thought that credential alone
would make me fall head over heels in
love with the idea of a Marianne
candidacy I've interviewed for her it's
just not for me is the way I like to say
it it's the the background of the
woo-woo type stuff is a bit off-putting
to me I understand that someone with
literal Christian Bible beliefs that
also I I don't like maybe I'm more
willing to accept as most of our
presidents of course have had those
views because they're otherwise more
qualified but some of the things that
she says just strike me as I just I just
don't know I'll give you an example
when she was on with Russell Brand she
said there's no such thing as clinical
depression it just means someone in a
clinic told you you have depression
I don't believe that to be the case I
think we have an understanding there's
two types of depression there's like a
genetic predisposition depression
there's like a acute some things
happening in my life temporary
depression okay you know when she was
asked about it recently she said
I didn't mean it I was just trying to
impress Russell Brand
I don't know if I'm more bothered by the
things she first said or by the fact
that she wanted to impress Russell Brand
but it's just like it's just really not
for me and I agree with her on we need
to take the climate more seriously we
need to expand access to hell I I'm with
all of that stuff now I want to say one
other thing about this
anybody who wants to run should run I am
not suggesting there should be an
uncontested primary for Joe Biden
absolutely so you think it should be
contested well what I mean by contested
is so there's two parts to what we mean
by contested will the DNC organize
debates and we'll get to that in a
second but should should anybody who's
on the left get out of the way because
Joe Biden is President and he's running
for re-election absolutely not the
question about should there be debates I
would like there to be debates the DNC
pretty clearly isn't going to organize
them I think if you did them you would
have to say at what polling level do you
qualify
and I don't know exactly where you put
that number but I think it would be a
great thing to put Joe Biden on a stage
with if you can get what six percent
eight percent I'm not really sure what
the number would be I'm totally all for
that
was a set of candidates at least from my
perspective so weak
do you have do you have an understanding
there's a lot of different answers to
this
one aspect to this which I think is more
of a socio-cultural thing which I've
recently read about to some degree is
the job actually turns off the people
who would be best at it because of what
you need to do to become president
and it includes
all but completely abandoning your
existing day-to-day life job which you
may depend on and family to some degree
it's horribly uh negative as we already
talked about
and at the end of all of that you either
lose and then have to rebuild and maybe
you're not in a position to be able to
do that or you win and then now you've
got four years of being one of the most
hated people no matter how good a job
you do so I think by its nature it turns
off a lot of people that would otherwise
be good
um I also think that there's a lot of
posturing from within the parties about
well you might be good but it's not your
time yet so you should wait and then
let's talk about maybe a senate seat
here and there so it's like it's like a
company essentially and they're figuring
out where they want to place people uh I
think all of these things make it so we
end up with candidates most people
aren't super thrilled with so it's
difficult for somebody who's young or an
outsider to uh
to quickly become a candidate I think
that that's true and I think also in a
lot of ways it's just not I mean would
you want to be president no I mean I
can't because I wasn't born in the U.S
so it's easy for me to say but
um if everyone says no
then we'll get the people that we have
no I understand that so I would love to
help somehow
sure and I feel like there's not even a
mechanism for helping except to the
Democratic through the voting process
but I'm just
annoyed how little technology there is
in the whole process how little
Innovation there is in the whole process
all of this the sad thing is this is
written about a lot which is
there's this thing called political
hobbyism
and I think there's a good chance that
some of the people in my audience are
political hobbyists in the sense that
they follow this stuff as entertainment
to some degree and I've written a lot
about how uh I've read a lot and talked
a lot about how okay we vote every two
years or every four years in our local
elections Etc and then we think about
politics all the time Neil Postman wrote
about this in his book amusing ourselves
to death but what are you actually going
to do about the kids Starving in this
country and the nuclear buildup in that
country okay if everybody refocused
their attention on their immediate
communities and that could mean any
number it could mean the town or city
you live in or it might mean
um an athletic club or whatever if
everybody this time they spent on
political hobbyism they moved somewhere
else which might put me out of a job
that's okay I'm willing to lose my job
because I think it would be so
beneficial then our communities would
just be that much better because you can
actually affect change in a much more
tangible way well locally whether it's
obvious people talk about potholes but
other things as well
yeah and I wish our system was more
amenable to that kind of contribution
hopefully through the digital space it
would be
let me ask you about on the Republican
side Ron DeSantis
what do you think of him as a candidate
running against uh Donald Trump I think
in the couple of weeks before our our
discussion today
his campaign which hasn't even started
has sort of started to implode and this
was something that I started thinking
about in September October he really
doesn't seem ready for prime time in the
sense that just being confronted and
confronted is not even the right word
just being asked about
uh some topics he didn't really seem to
want to talk about
he responded in such a sort of
disproportionate unhinged way during his
recent trip to Asia he was asked about
why aren't you or why are you responding
but in this weird way to Trump's attacks
on you and he went into this weird
bobble head thing with a weird smile and
something came out that didn't make any
sense and he sort of got mad at the
reporter and it was just like if you
can't handle that you can't be on a
debate stage with Donald Trump and again
for all my criticisms of trump the guy
gets you on a debate stage he can make
you look pretty silly he was recently
asked about his role at Guantanamo Bay
when he was an officer in I forget which
branch of the Armed Forces and he just
sort of attacked the journalist asking
the question and it just looked very bad
and there are increasingly big
Republican donors who are not fans of
trump and were sort of hoping to put
their eggs in the Rhonda santis basket
who are saying this guy just doesn't
have what it takes I don't think he can
do it so I don't know if DeSantis will
be able to get away once you're polling
20 something like he is and you haven't
even announced it's very attractive and
he probably to some degree is thinking
if I wait till 2028 I might not have
this opportunity again
but Trump's polling 5253 which means
even if DeSantis gets all of the current
non-trump vote he has to figure out how
to take something more for Trump from
Trump I just don't know how he does it
first of all the implosion aspect that's
that's part of the process isn't it you
kind of implode a bunch of uh a bunch of
times and then rebuild yourself and
rebuild them because the new cycle kind
of forgets it's possible the problem is
if he the first debate is in August
so that's only a few months away and the
decision is going to be have to be made
pretty soon and unless he can get a new
momentum going uh I just don't know how
he gets what he needs in order to really
have a shot so would anyone else run
against Donald Trump it's very tough
right now I mean there are other people
running there's this guy Vivek ramaswamy
who's running Nikki Haley is running her
campaign basically Dead on Arrival
um Trump actually does better in polls
the more people run when when it's just
him and DeSantis that's the best
scenario for DeSantis it's not great for
DeSantis but it's it's uh certainly
better
um but I think the difficulty is this is
a question for Republicans to figure out
the people who rightly recognized in
2016 that this guy is not good for their
party
um still believe this guy's not good for
their party but many of them recognize
that most of the voters are still behind
him
you can always say it's early his
polling doesn't really mean anything
anything could happen something major
would have to happen for Trump to lose
that lead if he got more uh if he was
arrested two more times and had more
indictments and it just became like this
guy can't even campaign because he's so
busy going from court to court maybe
that would make a difference it's really
tough to imagine
you said that there are three categories
of people who vote Republican and uh
that Trump introduced the fourth one uh
can you go through
the four categories sure so you've got
like your pro-business low tax
Republicans these are mostly people like
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney has a bit of the
social conservatism as well he's Mormon
and that's there but Mitt Romney
primarily particularly as a Northeast
sort of Republican I mean I know Utah
but governor of Massachusetts he is like
a low tax pro-business type guy you've
got your libertarian type Republicans
who are primarily about freedom and
liberty often they are actually more
socially liberal where they go I don't
care about gay marriage liberal you know
I don't care so much about abortion
um and that
overlapped a little bit with the Tea
Party Movement in 2010 although tea
party did have a religious component but
sort of like the libertarian
freedom-minded folks and then the
religious conservatives people that
support Canada it's like Josh Hawley or
uh Ted Cruz Etc where their big thing
are social issues often they actually
want uh Christianity being civil
government they don't want separation of
church and state those are traditionally
the three Republican groups the one that
Trump introduced was people who just
didn't really pay attention to politics
but either followed celebrity or had
grievances that they didn't yet have a
scapegoat for
um and were sort of right-leaning
culturally even though they didn't
attribute that to republicanism
and Trump was able to bring them into
politics often for the first time as
voters they could be part of any of
those three groups if they get more into
politics or kind of be their own thing
but they're more kind of like Cult of
Personality I'm here for Trump types did
it have to do anything about the culture
wars and the identity politics all that
kind of stuff
yeah I mean so in 2016 when Trump
mobilized them those weren't really
issues the way they are now so I think
at the time at that time it certainly
was not a factor what was the mobilizing
issue I know it was it just anti-hillary
in 2016. there he did a good job on
anti-hillary but a lot of it was
identifying real economic problems wage
depression lack of jobs in parts of the
country you know Ohio and Indiana Trump
rightly identified like we have an issue
here we don't have enough
entrepreneurship Etc
um but there was also a lot of
scapegoating that was you know China and
people coming through the U.S Mexico
border were popular scapegoats for a lot
of those problems this gets us kind of
to populism
populism is a rhetoric and populism as a
rhetoric doesn't necessarily come with
particular policies you can be
a populist uh a user of populist
rhetoric and proposed solutions that
would be more aligned with Bernie or
Tucker Carlson
populists will often identify the plight
of the middle class
the difference would be Bernie will say
we've got to put some restrictions on
how much uh billionaires can make and
we've got to reinvest in these social
programs Tucker will say BLM taking your
house and a brown person from Mexico
taking your job are what we need to deal
with
so the the populist rhetoric can lend it
lend itself to very different policy and
Trump used that very effectively in
2016. why do you think Hillary Clinton
was
hated as intense as she was by a certain
percent of the population it feels like
uh that's the first election eyewitness
where there's a lot of hate
maybe I'm misremembered I don't remember
Obama
um
I don't remember the degree of hate
there was a conspiracy theories that he
wasn't born in this country but I don't
remember hate towards Obama record death
threats under Obama more than any
previous president right towards who
towards him towards him yeah do you mean
more hate between voters or between
voters between voters but like
that's I guess what I was speaking to
but that hate was directed towards
um The Narrative the thread that
connected all of that in 2016 was
Hillary Clinton
few different things
um and I'm not ranking these these are
just all things that come to mind one is
Hillary Clinton
had been around in the political space
for a long time from her time as first
lady through a senator Secretary of
State Etc so I think that there was
enough time for different groups to
develop an antipathy towards her for
different reasons so time
um secondly
Trump's branding of her as crooked
was very effective yeah where there were
so many people demanding that she be
imprisoned if you ask them what is the
crime they don't know but she should
definitely be locked up that became a
very big thing
the email story as it were and uh James
Comey doing a second public event about
that investigation even though there
wasn't any actual news about it just
doing a second event about it at the
last minute I think hurt her and also
generated some hate and I don't find
Hillary Clinton to be particularly
likable although I voted for her I
thought she was the better candidate and
I think that there are others who also
didn't find her particularly likable
that those are a lot of impediments to
becoming president I was trying to
understand why there's so many
conspiracy theories about Clinton's in
general Bill Clinton and uh Hillary
Clinton
and I
maybe I'm not researched well enough
the of the why of it uh the Y of it
actually the extent of the conspiracy
theories the sort of the the conspiracy
theories that they've killed a lot of
people this kind of stuff it's hard for
me to speak to them because I'm aware
that they exist but I'm not an expert in
them because they seem so obviously
baseless to the degree that I've
researched them a little bit and then I
move on and uh you know it's been years
since I've looked at this stuff I know
there's the Seth Rich one and there's
the Clinton Body Count one I think
there's one connected to Epstein if I
recall correctly there's all sorts of
these different ones
um without speaking to any of them
specifically because I'm not the expert
on Clinton conspiracies uh it does seem
as though this stuff for so long has
generated an audience I mean I remember
in the supermarket when Bill Clinton was
President at the checkout seeing the
tabloids and there were stuff about
Hillary birth than alien baby and you
know all the it seems like it's been
titillating to people for a very long
time
well another question from Reddit
speaking of aliens uh I would be curious
to hear David's views on conspiracies
and conspiracy theories the extent to
which real conspiracies happen and why
conspiracies that have little evidence
behind them manage to be so compelling
to people regardless also please bring
up aliens and uaps okay where do we
start the conspiracy what uh so what in
general
as a person who uh thinks about politics
uh thinks about this world like where do
conspiracy theories fit in for you I
think there have been conspiracies and
by conspiracies I'm using a colloquial
definition which is basically uh
individuals working together to
um in a clandestine way impact or affect
some kind of event or phenomenon uh very
very broadly I mean certainly that those
things have happened
um the to pick to jump around to some of
the things that were in there I think
the reason that conspiracy theories are
so compelling is that it's really tough
for a lot of people to accept
there are random events
not predictable specifically at a
stochastic level we might be able to
predict them but specifically
unpredictable
bad events in many ways
I could be the victim of one or you
could or my family could that's really
scary to a lot of people understandably
so and for some people it's less scary
and more soothing in a way to say there
aren't really random events like this
somebody planned it and if we had just
known who planned it it just could have
been stopped because we would have known
exactly when
that's just a psychological level easier
to accept for people and I get that to
some degree because
listen it's it's not the most exciting
thing that everything can just be going
fine and something absolutely horrible
happens and kills who knows some number
of people or so I think that's the the
biggest attractor to a lot of these
conspiracy theories it doesn't apply to
all of them though but yeah but there's
still kind of a basic understanding of
human nature where people
some people are greedy and want power
and are corrupted by power
so there's a kind of these compelling
narratives that stick
that um
I don't know the vaccine is a is a
opportunity for a powerful billionaire
to implant chips into you so you can
control you further right
it doesn't seem
what do I want to say
it's like for some reason
that doesn't seem as crazy as it should
because you think like maybe Hollywood
contributes to that but you think yeah
you can imagine an evil person a person
that wants more control more power
um and is also at the same time able to
convince themselves as history shows
that they actually have the best
interest of the populace in mind that
they're trying to do good for the world
so they do evil while trying to do good
and you can kind of imagine it so it's
like why not
and uh do you listen to people in power
uh authorities they kind of look and
sound Shady
you know like yeah the the transparency
especially the older ones I think
younger folks are better at being like
real and transparent and just like
revealing their flaws and the basic
Humanity but people that are a little
bit older in the positions of power
they're more polished they're more like
there it feels like they're presenting a
narrative where the truth is hidden in
the shadows so I don't think there's
anything wrong with suspecting
maybe a public figure isn't giving me
the full story yeah totally reasonable
thing to question
um I don't think there's anything wrong
with exploring a lot of these different
things I think the problem becomes and I
know you've talked about this in so many
different ways with other guests the
problem becomes when we lose a shared
understanding of how we would assess
whether any of these things are true and
then both alleged evidence and an
absence of evidence both become
supportive of the conspiracy theory
because if there's bad evidence you
manipulate it and say it's good evidence
if there's no evidence you say the
evidence was obviously hidden by the
people who carried out the thing or
whatever so unless we can have a shared
understanding of how we would determine
what's true these are common
conversations often between atheists and
religious folks how can we deter like is
is my faith in something or my desire
for something to be true a good way to
evaluate whether it is true they're
really similar questions
well let me ask you about Trump on that
front about the election 2020 election
and
maybe the better questions about January
6th do you think January 6th was a big
deal
I do
how big of a deal compared to what
uh Civil War
I think it was less of a big deal than
the Civil War okay no I mean so you well
it's a very interesting thing though
right because we have not only the the
event that's that's clever actually it's
not only the event but it's what led up
to it and what has happened since and
did it change what is considered on the
table
that citizens can should or might do if
they disagree with the results of an
election so I think that there are
further reaching consequences than just
was the six hour period on January 6th a
bigger smaller deal than the Civil War
and there's so much wrapped up into it
um many conspiracy theories flowed from
January 6th as well uh 60 Minutes
recently featured a guy named Ray Epps
who was targeted by some on the right
um claiming that he was an instigator or
an agent of the FBI or something along
those lines uh there were people
claiming that no real TR was like a no
true Scotsman sort of thing like Trump
supporters wouldn't Riot so by
definition it must have been antifa uh
police let him in or police were you
know all these different things I think
it was a big deal in a lot of ways
because it completely made us have to go
back to the top to say okay what are the
parameters of valid discussion and
activism in the United States but what
aspect of the January 6 was bad for you
well
I mean like if you're thinking from a
big philosophical political perspective
so presumably the number of people hurt
and the number of people who died
is not the only metric to consider here
absolutely I think the sum total of what
it means about how the United States
operates is what's most concerning and
I'll kind of just like flesh it out a
little bit so
summer of 2020. Trump's already saying
they're going to cheat
now the polling
is close but it shows that Biden's in a
good position people aren't happy with
Trump any reasonable person would look
and say it's going to be close but Biden
certainly it wouldn't be a crazy thing
if Biden won Trump's already saying
they're going to cheat with mail-in
ballots or they're going to cheat with
early voting or they're going to cheat
with machines or we should do only in
person or whatever else the case may be
we have the election
we knew in certain States how the vote
count was going to go some states stop
counting at 10 pm some states count all
of the mail and stuff up front some
don't everything was completely
predictable
uh at 2 A.M Trump comes out and says I
won
okay but where are you getting that sir
as he claims people always refer to him
where are you getting that and with that
statement immediately we see that there
is a large portion of this country that
either is unable or unwilling to say
wait a second
the polling all said this was a real
possibility
the counting schedules are all being
adhered to
all but Trump won that doesn't make any
sense that doesn't happen it builds
people are donating Millions to Trump
for supposed audits which nobody can
Define and lawsuits which go nowhere and
it builds and builds and builds and we
have a total separation from a factual
reality there's no reason to think by
December 1st right give three weeks to
look through some of the stuff by
December 1st there's no reasonable case
to be made that Trump actually won
but it doesn't end there it goes into
maybe we can just like send different
electors even though Biden won Arizona
Let's just like send I don't remember
how many electors it is in Arizona Let's
just like send Republican electors to
say we vote for Trump but that's that's
not democracy that's not the way the
system works let's make sure we're ready
ready for what exactly and then it
builds to maybe Mike Pence can just like
prevent Biden from being president or
maybe we can just interfere in this
other way and then it gets to let's
break into the capital
it's the height of saying we no longer
comport ourselves attached to what is a
verifiable factual reality
and when we no longer do that we're also
willing to commit crimes property crimes
violent crimes okay different degrees in
order to try to have something other
than democracy it wouldn't be democracy
if any of those things had happened yeah
I I think it's not the height of it I
think
there's still a case to be made that
that did not leave the realm of protest
versus
a violation of the principles of
democracy so to me the height
of what could happen on January 6th is
uh if Donald Trump was much better
executive uh he could take control of
the military if it had succeeded
no not even succeeded the attempt would
have been more
um
empowered
I understand so like
the way not to bring up Hitler every
other word which is something your
subreddit also told me not to do okay
it's kind of an important figure it's
interesting to study that moment in
history because it reveals so much about
human nature and that all of us are
capable of Good and Evil but thank you
dear subredditor or redditor for your
contribution to the conversation I will
keep bringing up Hitler in the Third
Reich and I'll keep bringing up Stalin
there's so much to learn from that
anyway the
enough
um an effective practice authoritarian
could roll the tanks out into the city
streets
to uh establish order
and in so doing pause the process of
democracy
as opposed to a few protesters breaking
in to a questionably uh protected
building I agree that what you're saying
would be worse I don't want to use it to
minimize what the protesters were intent
on doing they failed fortunately I was
both to you the intention was there well
the intention was Trump should remain
president that's the intention and to
what length they would have been willing
to go if by the evening early evening
they you know were sort of like forced
out I don't know I agree with you that
Trump trying to use the military uh
would absolutely be worse you know
there's these reports that he tried to
seize voting machines which is kind of
funny because it's like once you get the
machine at Mar-A-Lago what do you do
with it exactly I don't know there's a
like a comedic element to Trump sitting
around with voting machines but he did
float trying to do some other things I
don't believe there's reporting that he
actually tried to use the military
I wondered to what degree this opened
the door to further things like this
with other uh other candidates on you
know even uh in the Democratic party
also
uh do you think there will be more and
more questioning of the election results
there has been already it's uh very
clearly The Playbook Kerry Lake lost she
ran for governor in Arizona 2022 she
lost what I mean by that is her opponent
received more votes it's like very clear
what it means that she lost she insists
to this day that she won
to this day she did the same grift Trump
did about donate we've got a case we won
in the case you didn't win they just set
a court date like doesn't know that's
not what you know lies upon grift upon
lies so they they did it then
um it is I I it's extraordinarily
saddening but it seems like this is now
going to be part of the Playbook do you
think people on the left will start
doing it
uh I don't have a reason to believe that
that is going to happen but I'm not
going to say it never could absolutely
it certainly could people on the left
could start using it as a tactic right
now there's not a sign that that's going
to happen but it's certainly good my
expectation is and I'm not a betting man
but I would bet money if Joe Biden loses
in November of 2024
he will say I lost he will call the
winner he will concede and he will leave
the White House in an orderly fashion
you don't think there will be claims of
a hacked election the the ability to
hack elections is becoming uh
more and more effective
with the developments on the artificial
intelligence side the difficulty is
you're basically saying
will something happen without me knowing
anything about the election imagine
there really was evidence of a hacked
election then I would want those claims
to be made but the way elections have
gone in the past I I don't expect that
that's a claim that would be made no
speaking of evidence of things uh that
were claimed
what do you think about the hunter Biden
laptop or as you tweeted the laptop from
Hell
the laptop from Hell TM right uh to what
degree was this uh laptop story
important and to what degree was it not
at this point
I have said many times
if there is any reason to believe that
Hunter Biden Joe Biden Naomi Biden Jill
Biden Hillary Obama Doug M if there's
any evidence any of them committed a
crime they should be investigated
they should be charged
and they should be tried period
the hunter Biden laptop thing has been
floating around for so long
and we still have zero actual
uh pieces of evidence of any crime
particularly involving Joe Biden there's
the claim from some that references to
the big guy are about Joe Biden getting
10 percent for some illicit it's been
years they've been saying this they've
not been able to bring forward any
evidence on it so my assessment of the
hunter Biden laptop is
it seems to mostly be a story about nude
images released without someone's
consent which is illegal in Most states
and violates Twitter's own policies
that's the main story to me beyond that
I don't know how many people have a copy
of this hard drive at this point Rudy
had it Tucker do you remember when
Tucker this this is this is unbelievable
Tucker said that he mailed himself
a copy a USB stick yeah and it got lost
in the mail you you have the mother lode
proving the criminality of Joe and
Hunter Biden and I don't you just
dropped it off with a stamp and it got
lost in the mail you don't have a backup
copy you don't so I'm ready for the
evidence to come forward Hunter Biden
has nothing to do with Joe Biden's
Administration but as a person who if he
committed a crime charge him investigate
him whatever but it's it's getting it's
almost getting satirical the degree to
which they're talking about the hunter
Biden laptop uh what do you think about
the the social media aspect of this that
that story got censored
and what do you think about censorship
in General on social media that that
story during an important time in the
electoral process got censored so I uh
as a matter of principle I think we have
to Define what we mean by censorship but
I'm against censorship short of illegal
content I guess is the way I would put
it I do respect the company's right to
have terms of service and to enforce
them as long as they're not illegal if
Twitter were to say we don't publish
content from Jewish people okay now
we've got a problem on our hands but
um what what is dubious to me
is the claim that had people been able
to see Hunter Biden's genitals they
would have voted for Trump which I know
it's like David you're you're making
light of and but at the end of the day
what exactly is the claim that if you
had known more about Hunter Biden I
guess allegedly hiring prostitutes and
and having a drug problem and seeing
pictures you wouldn't have voted for Joe
Biden I mean I know me as a voter I
don't feel that way
I think uh it's less about the content
of the story and about the actions of uh
a social media company
to control what you see and what you
don't see so you can imagine a social
media company like Facebook and Twitter
making the same kind of decision about a
more impactful story than uh a few dick
pics on a laptop well I think if that
happened then my view might be different
right but I do my general view though on
the hunter Biden story is
had the Articles not contained those
images that were illegal in many states
and violated Twitter's policies I would
say publish it absolutely I don't think
it would have had an impact but I would
be in favor of it being of the links
being allowed a hundred percent
okay uh you mentioned Tucker what do you
think about talking getting fired from
Fox
um you're a media person that works
independently yes
uh Tucker was a media person who doesn't
work independently right
uh yeah what do you what do you think
about that particular situation is it
representative of some big shift that's
happening in mainstream media
what would the ship be uh basically
mainstream media freaking out because
the funding is getting less and less and
less and less and there's going to give
more power to individual
commentators basically Tucker Carlson
just starting a podcast
so the YouTube channel I think that's
what he should do I think that's the
most profitable path rather than maybe
going to work for Newsmax or whatever
the case may be but the firing
fundamentally was not a politically
oriented firing that suggests Fox News
is changing its tune politically in any
way there's no evidence of that
whatsoever
um Tucker Carlson basically became a
legal problem for Fox News there's
really Four Points to it one is the 787
and a half million dollar settlement
with Dominion partially was because of
the
um claims that went out on Tucker
Carlson's program so to some degree
Tucker's program was a prominent uh node
of the problematic claims that became
the subject of the lawsuit that's number
one number two smartmatic which is
another voting Machine Company still has
a similarly sized lawsuit against Fox
News based on the exact same sorts of
claims it may cost Fox News again so
this is now two problems that Tucker's a
big contributor to number three former
Tucker staffer has brought a lawsuit and
I don't remember the exact claims but I
know that there are claims of different
types of discrimination it seems like it
has legs and that may be a third payout
related to Tucker Carlson and based on
the 60 Minutes piece from a few weeks
ago Ray Epps saying Tucker ruined his
life by fomenting conspiracies about him
around January 6th that's ripe for
another lawsuit so to me
Tucker's firing was a risk mitigation
strategy uh of many that will be
employed as as these lawsuits come
forward there's no evidence that it's
because
Fox didn't like and what we mean by that
who are we talking about Rupert Murdoch
doesn't like or the pre I don't know but
I don't have any reason to believe it's
because Tucker's ideas were no longer
welcome on Fox certainly the audience
liked them so interesting it's not about
it's not even about the ratings
it's about just the the legal costs
Fox is interesting the ratings question
is interesting because Fox unlike most
other or every other cable news channel
they negotiate a fee from every cable
subscriber if you have Fox News as a
channel even if you don't watch it Fox
gets a little bit of money they are
dramatically less dependent on ad
Revenue than CNN and MSNBC so the
ratings question is an interesting one
but Fox's position is different on that
another question from Reddit
both sides are the same in quotes is a
meme notion that has spread
far and wide in American political
discourse on the internet to what extent
do you agree or disagree with this
notion and why do you think it is so
popular now
this Reddit comment also says that
podcasts like Russell Brand and Joe
Rogan or the legendary comic George
Carlin are examples of big proponents of
this notion
all of which I kind of disagree with
uh Russell Brand Joe Rogan and George
Carlin
claim that both sides are the same the
same and use that you know all
politicians are crooked and they suck
and this kind of thing I don't know if
they're
I don't know if that's true maybe George
Carlin anyway let's leave that aside
yeah uh to what degree do you think
I do agree with this notion that both
sides are the same left and right
the Crooked corrupt politicians they do
what politicians do I don't agree that
it's the same I think there are
different factions that like to say that
um for different reasons there are some
individuals who want to present
themselves as kind of being Above The
Fray of partisan politics and so it's be
it I call it enlightened centrism
um do you mean that positively no I mean
it negatively yeah it's it's a bit of a
pejorative the idea that I am not going
to fall for being a democrat or a
republican I can see that these are just
two sides of the same coin
equally bad lying to ever okay so that's
one it's sort of like it's popular at
dinner parties in some circles to go I'm
but with all these politicians you know
left and right so that's one side of it
the other side of it is that it's often
used when when your side has really
stepped in it it's a popular way
to acknowledge that your side has done
something wrong
but while framing it as it's not
uniquely wrong and it's not worse than
what anybody else does and I find that
it's one of the lamest and most kind of
cringe-inducing things to hear because
of the what comes next and usually what
comes next is not
a good accurate criticism of something
that took place and a discussion of how
to solve a real problem that we have I
find that a conversation Stifler it also
is used to kind of suppress voter
turnout not actively it's not that the
people who say that go around saying
don't vote but the idea of course is the
more people that believe that it doesn't
really make a difference who you vote
for it's going to suppress voter turnout
and I want voter turnout to be as high
as possible not as low as possible so I
also dislike it for that reason
so is it possible to say that one side
is worse than the other in in modern
current political
climate listen I'm a person on the left
I'm not pretending to come here as as
and not knowing that my view is biased
because I'm a person of the left if you
ask Ben Shapiro he'll tell you something
different I think in 2023
sum total the influence of the American
right wing
if the American right wing were to get
everything it wants
it would be a horrifying reality if the
left were to get everything it wants
we'd have to figure out a few things
including exactly how we pay for certain
programs
but they're mostly noble goals and I
believe that they are more supportive of
an individual
self-determining what they want to do in
life and how they want to live and is
more in line with the idea of freedom
and liberty than what the right is
currently proposing that's my view
and of course people will disagree with
me and they know we get to freedom and
liberty the way that the right wants to
do it okay well we can have that
conversation so
I think you've implied in your answer it
was kind of focused on policy
it felt like it was focused on policy
there's other stuff that people worry
about sure
um particularly with the left
uh What uh may be termed the woke mind
virus
where have I heard who's using that term
a lot now I'm trying to think I'm not
sure I'm not sure not sure what comes up
uh but the cultural aspect of this that
um
you know if you give a lot of power to
people on the left as you've gave as an
example there would be a lot of kind of
censorship a suppression of speech and a
kind of uh dividing up of a society of
who is allowed to
um
basically a reallocation of resources
not based on Merit but based on some
kind of high ethical Notions of what is
right and only a very small percent of
the population gets to decide what is
what is fair what is right
which is you know uh we already have a
small portion of the population deciding
Fair okay yes but I don't know I don't
know how many different ways I can say
kind of a negative characterization of
uh of folks on the left when we're now
comparing it just as a to play Devil's
Advocate sure so is that is that
something that you worry about so Paul
the setting policies aside uh wokeism
yes how big of a problem is it this is a
great conversation so let's two sides of
it okay we have new polling that seems
to suggest so-called wokism is kind of
more popular in the United States than
anti-wokism and I'll tell you what I
mean by that this is the less
interesting part we'll go to the more
interesting part second
um people sometimes what people mean by
wokism is an overreaction
to a perceived
Injustice
that goes beyond what would be fair and
equitable
there was this really interesting poll
in it ask questions like for example do
you believe Society has gone too far not
far enough or just about the right
amount in dealing with issues affecting
the trans community
the woke position which is society
hasn't gone far enough was far more
popular than we've gone too far now the
the right-wing media narrative is we've
gone way too far this is out of control
and there are lots of other similar
answers it's not a huge margin a lot of
these are like 58 to 42 60 to 40. it's
not like 90 to 10 but by a small margin
the so-called woke perspective of we
actually haven't yet done enough to fix
some of these issues is a little bit
more popular so if we went back to
DeSantis this is part of why I think
desantis's anti-woke agenda may just be
a political misstep that's really
interesting result I wonder how the
questions are
framed
but it's it's still interesting
nevertheless no matter what to hear that
people are majority of people in America
awoke and not in the negative sense of
the word the poll didn't use the term
woke right right this is a critical
thing let's use the term World
positively the term has kind of been
perverted yes four years ago when the
term was started to be used I would have
said oh yeah woke just means like I have
become aware of problems that are bigger
than any one person can fix for
themselves that relate to the system I
think that's what and we might disagree
on which problems fall under that
category but like it was kind of benign
I think now it just means like
outrageously
left wing maybe even with socialist or
Marxist undertones it's become a
pejorative at this but also like bullies
like people sure censorers yeah but
people that go around calling others
racist uh sometimes oftentimes without
any proof of or justification fair but
that's worse that's that's a few folks
on Twitter you're saying like the
polling is starting to show that like no
they're still
uh most Americans still care about these
issues and want to yeah want to improve
and want to make progress I think that's
the case and they want to do it in a
genuine way that doesn't suppress or
oppress anybody but now let me get to
like to what degree do I think that
actual when it goes too far is a problem
it absolutely exists it we can find
instances of where this exists on the
left
um I've been told many times that as a
Jewish Argentinian immigrant to the
United States
I actually don't qualify as oppressed
enough
because Jews are privileged now in the
U.S and my family had just enough money
to leave Argentina so there's this kind
of like oppression Olympics thing where
I've been told you don't get to comment
for example like a topic in the Latino
Community now is are you familiar with
latinx okay in Spanish there's an
analogous movement
where words by their nature sort of like
have a gender so like the word for
friend is Amigo
but if it's a woman you would say Amiga
so right from there you can tell the
gender that we're talking about and if
it's a mixed group you say amigos it's
the male with an S but it could include
both there's a movement now which wants
to do away with that and put the letter
E in it's a new word okay it's a
gender-neutral word amigues
totally new I don't like that and I
don't know anyone no one in my family
uses it and I think it's kind of like a
strange imposition from someone kind of
with with a solution in search of a
problem I've been told you moved to the
U.S long ago and like your English is
good and like you look white and say
like you don't get to weigh in on that
that I think is an example if I
understand correctly of the type of of
thing you're talking about I'm I'm kind
of being bullied I'm fine I'm surviving
fine but I'm being bullied over it and
disqualified and saying you don't get to
speak on this issue all of those
examples all of that stuff
I am completely against and I tell
people on the left we're actually
hurting our own movement with this stuff
I just don't think it's as big as some
others believe it you don't think it's
an existential threat to uh our
civilization in the west to West no I
don't and and I mean look we've got a
Biden Administration I see Biden as
Center left those who see Biden as
extreme far left this stuff has played
almost no role whatsoever in the first
two plus years of his administration
well there's people that see him far
left as far left
there's people on the right who I mean
Trump says Biden's a Marxist Socialist
Communist
um I haven't heard that because I don't
think that would stick uh very much he
says it at every rally yeah
which I love to tell us that you don't
watch these things it's like How Deeply
researched you are in Trump I can only
imagine how good your Trump oppression
is at this point it's not very sadly
it's not it's not all right no but and
I'll say one other thing on on that you
know take trans because Tran just to
talk about it a little bit we haven't
dealt with it much the trans issue has
become huge I believe because the right
is obsessed with it the right is very
much not concerned with gay men anymore
it used to be that gay men is like oh we
have to stop gay men from adopting and
unnatural and pedophiles now it's trans
it's drag shows Etc I do think that
there is a fair question to say how do
we deal with trans women in a very small
short list of sports that's real okay
my view though is I go okay we have all
issues we have issues related to gender
and sexual orientation we have issues
related to Trends within that we have
specifically Sports you can eliminate
from that uh trans men nobody's worried
right about women biological women who
are transmit and then when you say it's
only in certain sports that it matters
hey I'm right there I think it's a
complicated question I don't know how we
deal with it I would ask leagues that
have experience with this already and
whatever the problem I have is
pretending that the the uh Vanguard of
left-wing politics right now is trying
to force trans women into sports it's
like it's just not the big issue that
the right is reacting as if it were but
perhaps because of the right it's
forcing the left uh to
to continue discussing it I mean I I
feel like it uh even in institutions
even at universities it feels like these
ideas of diversity inclusion and Equity
are taking some of the air out of the
room
of um what a university should also care
about which is uh Merit
and it feels like re-prioritization
is going a little too far the other way
meaning
prioritizing this kind of amorphous
concept of diversity is moving away is
giving power to people that don't care
about Merit and I just want to bully
people with a big stick that says racism
or sexism or
um anti-diversity
and it it kind of suffocates the people
that uh care about Merit about
meritocracy about inspiring people from
all kinds of backgrounds to succeed and
it's just you kind of observe that I'm
sure that happens in all kinds of
Institutions and the concern I think the
people that are concerned about wilkism
are concerned about at scale what impact
does that have on a society when there's
so much conversation about racism and a
decrease oppression not to talk about
Merit like who's the actual good person
in the room the best person in the room
generically that's a concern to me the
degree to which it's happening at
different institutions
I think is worthy of exploration I know
people who work in Academia that are
getting out of Academia because they
don't like the environment on their
campuses for exactly the reason you're
saying so it exists there is no question
about it I also think that the idea of a
perfect meritocracy is is maybe not
necessarily the goal in the sense that
um when you talk about perfect
meritocracy someone wrote a book about
this who I interviewed about a year and
a half ago and whose Name Escapes Me
There are problems with a perfect
meritocracy I think what we want to do
is generate roughly equal
um uh um opportunity for people
understanding that there is going to be
an outcome on a gradient or a bell curve
allowing people generally speaking to
determine the path that they want to
take and giving them if it's possible
the ability to uh pursue that without
suppressing limiting I mean this is like
relatively uncontroversial stuff among I
would argue 95 of the left
with the caveats of what you're talking
about which I agree exist it would be
nice to know the actual data sometimes
people blow stuff out of the proportion
what is it's hard it's hard to measure
how much self-censorship happens at
University campuses that's true I think
also it's sort of like the The Pit Bull
bite stories thing where when a pit bull
bites a person it's more likely to be
reported on because it fits a certain
narrative and there are right-wing
Publications that are very interested in
making this seem as if it is an epidemic
I'm the first to say it is happening to
a degree I don't know the degree that
it's happening to I know a lot of people
in Academia only a couple of them say
that it's an issue
would they say it though if they
believed it I think they would say it to
me these are just personal contacts it's
not like I'm going to go blabbing to
push back uh I kind of agree with you
but at the same time most I mean I'm
deeply connected in Academia I have a
huge number of colleagues most people
self-censor by not thinking about it at
all they're like screw it that's deeper
whatever yeah I'm just gonna focus on
the thing I love doing which is the work
and they don't think about
uh they basically remove themselves from
politics and social issues and they just
kind of say I'm going to do my
engineering I'm going to do my
mathematics sure the problem with that
is it's kind of you can't go anywhere
further to figure it out it's sort of
like there's this funny clip where
Jordan Peterson says even atheists are
actually religious they just don't know
it and it's like it's hard to test that
you know I don't know okay I mean I
don't I don't but it's a it's a fair
point I mean there may be some people if
it has become so toxic for some people
they may have repressed it way down into
their subconscious but I don't know how
we would know that but you you know
symptoms of it because when certain
people speak up
kind of lightly
and then a 19 year old or a 20 year old
responds and is outraged the fact that
the administration listens to that 19
and 20 year old and then reprimands
whoever spoke up a little bit
that's a really dangerous sign to me and
I don't really care about these like so
I I'm more with you I don't think it's a
big issue but then I notice it I wonder
wait a minute
with this kind of environment allow a
young Noam chowski to be around would
this environment allow like uh I don't
know like uh
what tenure was designed for which is
to have controversial thinkers and not
kind of weird controversial things but
really people that challenge
things that should be challenged yeah I
I sympathize with that significantly I
always try to look at specific examples
yeah and sometimes I'll look at people
I'll ask for them and people will send
me five and one of them is a legit bona
fide example of what we're talking about
and four are kind of like ah there was a
complaint and it was investigated but
the teacher's tenure was never in
Jeopardy and yeah I don't know that I
chalk this up to a big woke event what
do you think the kind of apparatus of
the four-year degree in college is going
to look like in 20 years
oh that's I mean we're like day by day
that seems to be changing with GPT I
don't know if you've gotten a chance to
interact with chai GPT absolutely my
entire show now is written by Chachi
I mean there's uh that's partially a
joke uh it is only because it stopped
looking at the internet at 20 in 2021.
if it was current I could completely
just tune it out no I'm kidding but it's
a fascinating tool and uh it's changing
the nature of how we uh do homework
assignments it's changing the nature of
how we learn how we look up new
information how we explore information
how we care about things we're
interested in I think it
um I I don't think we'll have
value for a University degree in 20
years the way we do now I just think it
changes everything I think uh language
models I mean Google search has already
in Wikipedia has already
transformed I would say our civilization
but it's there was still a value for
basic education I don't I think that
starts to dissipate uh with with child
GPT so I don't I don't know yeah um I I
really I really don't think there's a
university the way we think of a
university in 20 20 30 years the I mean
I have a personal interest in it in that
my daughter is 10 months old and I'm
doing the 529 account I'm going through
the motions as if
but I also recognize you know if she
went to the schools I went to just with
the rate of tuition increase you're
talking 200k a year by the time she's
18. and what happens with wages relative
to that this is like separate from the
technological thing
um and in my mind I'm thinking is this
going to continue being the right path
what I would love to see is so many
people that I interact with just by
virtue of what I do
have no foundation in critical thinking
epistemology philosophy or media
literacy and
if there were some way to make that the
core of some basic education that
everybody's receiving
which goes beyond you know chat GPT can
do so many things but I've not yet seen
good examples of how it can teach you to
think maybe you have a different view on
how chat gbt can teach a user to think
but those skills seem to be so lacking
and so many of the people I interact
with if there's any positive change to
come from a changing Dynamic with higher
education I wish it would be to go in
that direction well no
um chat GPT is actually much better
helping me think than any educator even
books that I've encountered because it
it's very good at presenting the full
picture even better than a lot of
Wikipedia articles you know on questions
like did the virus leak from a lab
it just presents to you all the
different hypotheses the amount of
evidence available to it it's like it's
like a full calm objective picture of it
there's no partisanship it's like a
really nice list of things that's
available but I guess what I mean is
does it tell you how as a thinking human
you should evaluate the strength of each
of the paragraphs it presents to you you
can literally ask you can ask it to do a
fair okay yeah and then it's actually a
fun
it's fun to ask Chad GPT that question
because you'll get good answers and so
you basically uh have a kind of Socratic
like uh a deep intimate like great
podcast style conversation with an AI
system
every single day for as many hours as
you want as it especially as it improves
as and as the interfaces by which you
communicate with the thing improves so
yeah I think I think it will do exactly
that which is teach you how to think
because you will offload the memory of
facts and
um equations and whatever else uh School
teaches you you'll offload that to Ai
and instead you'll be using your human
mind which is uh what it for now is
uniquely good at which is asking good
questions thinking uh through the
complexities of issues when there's
multiple perspectives on it all of that
well then I stand corrected maybe then I
don't know what college is going to be
in 20 years well but you were sort of
commenting it I see to the the financial
aspect of it like why does it even make
sense yeah
I'm thinking about the transformative
effects of AI and what it starts to ask
what is the
what is even education right what do you
suppose what is the purpose of education
so one is to give you a kind of a
background knowledge of on a bunch of
different topics but the other is to
discover the thing you're truly
passionate about and the thing you're
really good at such that you can make
money and you can contribute to society
and have a fulfilling life yeah and also
learning to interact with other people
without relationships are built
socializing and so many other things as
well but is that you know that is the
big value of University yeah and maybe
you should be called something else can
you get that for less than 200k a year
exactly or else yeah no it's a fair
question a kind of social club and you
know one of the things I think about
also is people who are well connected I
mean this has always been this isn't new
right but if you're well connected and
you have a sort of drive towards
entrepreneurship and doing your own
thing and you're not pursuing a field
that is very licensing dependent like
medicine or law
um getting started four years earlier
with some internships can be a privilege
in some cases but again that's that path
is available to the people that would
likely do well regardless of whether
they went to college and so it's a very
privileged self-selected group anyway
another question from Reddit uh ask
David to explain why American style
libertarianism is an unserious
philosophy I don't know what they mean
by American style libertarianism I've
talked before about these kind of
utopian Libertarians where uh you know
we have we don't have police you just
kind of like hire a for-profit company
if you want protection and if there's a
conflict between two of these private
security companies then I don't know you
figure it out somehow so it's almost
like anarchism
if by I don't know what the question
means by that American style
libertarianism but in general my
problems with libertarianism as it is
often presented
come from the work of Sociology as well
as human psychology which is the reality
that once you get a group that's bigger
than 150 people
you really have to start centralizing
some decisions unless you're going to
subdivide the 150 endlessly into 275s
that now no longer have contact but then
that's not really one Society now it's
two I've not seen good evidence and I've
read a fair bit about this that once you
get Beyond 150 you can keep all
decisions decentralized and once you say
some things need to be centralized then
it's a matter of how you do it and it's
going to be some version of government
that conflicts with aspects of
libertarianism
well it could be companies right it
could be um it could be more Market
driven which is the idea of anarchism
that you're not you don't give any
centralized entity of Monopoly over
violence
you know and then if you think that the
markets are efficient
at delivering especially in this 21st
century and beyond
where a market could have perfect
information about people so one of the
issues is that you can manipulate
markets because there's not perfect
information but now in a digital age we
can uh we can be
higher bandwidth participants in the
market so if you're choosing between
different security companies or you're
choosing between different providers
different Services you can do so more
efficiently and more effectively
and in the digital space so you could
kind of imagine it but we haven't
successfully done it
uh without governments yeah and I think
there's a practical once you get Beyond
150 you also start specializing
um it just is a matter of fact you don't
have everybody isn't growing their own
food some people grow the food and other
people do other things and you come
across a lot of the problems that
started at the Agricultural Revolution
and whether you say that it's a company
that's solving it or a government the
problems are going to be very similar
and I've not read anything that to my
satisfaction explains how you deal with
that well there's underlying principles
of libertarianism which is putting
priority at the freedom of the
individual right
and that's compelling notion yeah
whenever I do these various political
Compass things that put you on two axes
on the authoritarian libertarian axis I
am way down on the libertarian side as a
left libertarian so my Tendencies are
always
anti-authoritarian and and
towards that option when it makes sense
so I sympathize with that a lot
another question from Reddit ask David
what issues he disagrees with you on is
there something new idea okay that's
good there you go there's no issues
perfect agreement
uh what's your view on Tesla that's it's
a good opportunity to ask what do you
think is
strengths and weaknesses of Elon Musk
uh you mentioned Twitter have you paid
your eight dollars I have not paid my
dollars I don't see the point in paying
for it I have no problem paying for
services I use a ton of services I'll
try the free I'll go to the paid
um right now so the way I used to use
the verified feed was I would post a
tweet and then the next day when I you
know review what's going on in my social
media I would look at the replies to the
Tweet which would give me a mix of
replies from verified and unverified
people but then I also look at the
verified and see who that are
verified public folks have responded to
me or maybe I want to engage with or
whatever the case may be
there's I don't even understand why I
would look at the verified feed anymore
so I never do because it's random folks
who I don't know and it sort of lost its
utility to me and then yeah sorry to
interrupt but the idea is if everybody
who's human pays the eight dollars it
shows to you that it's not Bots it's at
least humans from the reports about the
number of people that have bought the
blue check mark I think we may be a
thousand years from enough signups in
order to make that sort of like a
reality that was the idea it's an
interesting idea honestly
from my experience the obviously I was
seeing all sorts of attack comments some
of which were I'm sure from Bots but I'm
ignoring all of those comments anyway so
it really didn't affect my my experience
that much I mean here's the thing about
Elon and I say this people sometimes
like David you you obviously hate Elon
or you obviously love Elon I was
an investor in Tesla starting in 2015
I've since sold all my shares great run
um I'm on my second Tesla right now
I probably won't get a third one because
I think that electric vehicle technology
is now maturing such that when my lease
is up I'm going to have many more
options with the range and charging
Network that's important to me but I
could be wrong maybe you know I don't
know I have no the Cults of personality
around people they mean nothing to me so
for me it's just like people are people
nobody has only good ideas fine I think
that what Elon Musk did accelerating and
pushing forward the battery and electric
vehicle technology is unbelievable it's
it's a it's a one person
wrecking ball in the best sense of
saying we're not going to slow play this
and do okay now Toyota has a Toyota
hasn't actually entered but now whoever
we've got a 90 mile range car and next
year it'll be 110 and it's just like
we're doing this right now you can
compete or you can opt out and look at
what's happened fantastic
on the Twitter side of things I don't
really get the whole plan I don't know
if it started maybe as kind of a goof of
some kind and it developed into I guess
I have to buy it and I think something
about it ended up with there was a
clause invoked where I think he did try
to get out of buying it but then was
forced you to some degree yeah he was
forced the way Twitter used to work was
you followed people
and when you looked at your feed you
either saw the posts from the people you
were following in Reverse chronological
order or posts from the people you
followed algorithmically tailored to
what you're most likely to want to see
and if
you didn't follow someone you generally
wouldn't see their posts unless it was
like a sponsored tweet or someone you
follow quoted or retweeted them fine the
for you feed Tick Tock I believe First
had a so-called for you feed the idea is
this is stuff you might like based on I
don't know what either demographic data
about you your other habits whatever and
so it's useless to me it's just it's
just basically mostly right-wing content
that that is not interesting what do you
think that is I mean so uh the the
signals that are used to generate the
for you page is looking at all your uh
likes all your comments all your uh
blocks and mutes and all that you know
that I mean I don't know what it's
looking at okay so it's supposed to be
very pleasant for you I'm sure other
people go wow this for you thing is
awesome and I'll get like if you had
insert some right wing or sitting here
there we go Twitter used to suppress
right-wing voices and now finally
they're getting the fair shake that they
deserve in the fur you feed okay I mean
I wonder if there's a left-wing folks
uh setting their feelings of ilana's
side that are enjoying the for you page
that's a really important question
because it's supposed to be people on
the left-hand people on the right should
be enjoying the for you page sure yeah I
mean so for me my thought on Elon is
some incredible successes
I don't know about Twitter I do think
that I I don't believe Elon is a right
winger and when you see interviews with
him
um certainly at least socially and in
many ways culturally seems very moderate
or even somewhat on the left in my
experience or I don't think it's elon's
a right winger I don't that's not an
interesting critique it does seem though
that throughout the Twitter Escapade he
certainly ended up closer
to some voices that may be influencing
him in a particular way uh that's giving
some people that impression you know but
as far as like the Elon hate or the Elon
love it's just it's just a person who's
done some interesting things some of
which I like and some of which I could
kind of leave leave aside I have seen uh
folks
be
drift towards the right more
in response to just the viciousness of
attacks from the left like who I well
Elon and so so you just you do think
he's drifted towards the right uh
in uh so I don't think at the core but I
think on the surface okay I think uh and
I think Joe Rogan has as well on the
surface because I think maybe you can
correct me but it feels like people on
the left attack more viciously
um that has not been my experience well
oh it hasn't no this so so yeah let me
know because my sense was that they
attacked people on the left viciously as
well left attacks the it's its own
because you're not Progressive enough
you're not uh you know it's just this
kind of bullying that happens very
intensely no you're a hundred percent
right that when the left
has attacked me
um it's almost as vicious as when the
right attacks me the difference in my
experience is
it's a smaller contingent on the left
that's willing to Levy those attacks
against me but I'm on the left so to
some degree you could say well that
that's to be expected
um there is toxicity on the left but
it's intense isn't it like that's what I
mean like the attacks on people who are
on the left just uh you're not left
enough yeah that's no that's the and it
is a small number of people I can't deny
that that is absolutely uh absolutely a
a real phenomenon and um it depending on
what sort of topics you take on publicly
you are going to suffer the wrath of
that to a greater or or lesser degree
but with all of these things what I
always go back to is you know I probably
would have more disagreements with Rogan
today than the last time I was on his
show which was like at the beginning of
the pandemic but there would be zero and
I've done Clips critical of things that
he has said substantive of course
to me it's sort of like oh yeah I could
sit down with him and do a podcast and
it would be zero big deal and I would
tell them I stand by everything I said
about what you said and I would say it
to you right now there are people who
write to me and go oh man things must be
really really tense now if you were to
Rogan would never have you on because
you disagreed and he loves you I'm sure
he's just not thinking of me I'm not the
most important thing to Joe Rogan I
think both of us would be able to sit
down and talk about every one of my
criticisms it would not be taken
personally and then we would move on and
it would be the next day you get
attacked a lot
how do you not let that break you
mentally
oof I don't know uh so let's see
I try to I mean I'm in a toxic space the
news in politics partisan news and
politics partisan news and politics on
the internet with a social media
component just completely and totally
toxic from a personal perspective when
I'm done producing my last show of the
week
until Monday I try to completely tune
out from news and politics altogether
um and also make an effort to just not
look at feedback and and what's going on
I also really limit my Vis my visibility
uh I don't need to read every comment I
don't need to look at every email or
every tweet I have 15 minutes each day
where I go through my social media
platforms look at generally what is the
reaction been
maybe include that in my assessment of
how I want to tackle a certain issue if
I missed a good point or something like
that and basically try to move on when
something like we've talked about at the
beginning happens it becomes obsessive I
mean it's unhealthy right where I'm
going oh my God who's attacking me now
and scrolling it it becomes uh you know
I'm sweating it's horrible but I think
this like limiting exposure to that and
remembering that it is impossible to
please everybody yeah and so I'd really
rather have fresh genuine views each day
rather than views that are sort of like
uh restricted and flattened by what I
perceive to be people's preferences
uh so just can you speak a little more
to the full process of creating the
David backman show like what as you wake
up because you're doing
five shows a week I have the Letterman
schedule which means I do five shows in
four days I shoot Monday to Thursday but
we're doing five episodes basically uh
our guests we schedule in advance I'm
picking six to eight stories each day
that are like I said a blend of stuff I
think will be interesting things I want
to talk about and things where there's
it's being discussed at one layer and I
want to go deeper on it and I feel like
I'm able to do that
I choose those stories in the morning
record in the early afternoon and we put
the show out by that afternoon
what the preparation what's the how do
you take notes
uh are you on a sheet of paper no sheets
of paper anymore I used to do sheets of
paper I found something about it like it
worked the tactile nature of it it
became inconvenient for sharing the
notes with my team but basically we use
a Wiki type system it's called media
Wiki which is basically like a Wikipedia
clone old school yeah old school so we
can have Pages for every guest every
topic oh that's interesting I haven't
heard that yeah we I don't know anyone
else was using it it works really well
it it's so fast and it takes up almost
no space so it just is a really good
Tool uh when my team you know when we
book a guest and they have notes from
the publicist they'll put it in there
and then I can access it so I'm
basically working off of notes rather
than a script I'll pull any audio visual
stuff that I want so that that's
available
um and it's I mean it's it's really a uh
very seamless you know we're doing this
every day four days a week and so we
have it down to a well-oiled machine
where do you get ideas
everywhere
um I have
a bunch of subreddits that I follow that
I think are talking about interesting
things I have a curated list for which I
still use Twitter and it is very good
for this it's a curated private list of
journalists that I think are doing
interesting work so I'll see what's
there look at the sort of standard news
reporting wire Services AP and Reuters
glance at what everything from drudge to
CNN to whoever is covering that day look
at Google News
how do you try to fact check
stuff on your own show it's like is
there sources or is there a process I
always try to get to a primary source
first and foremost for the facts of the
story and then I'll use other tools for
background research oftentimes
Wikipedia's footnotes I find to be
useful tools chat GPT is a good one it
you really have to fact check it but
it'll give you ideas of where to do the
fact checking which I think is fantastic
sometimes it gives me information it's
flat out wrong and when you ask for the
source it's like oh yeah that actually
is not real
um which is okay it's part part of the
process yeah but um and then when
there's like an expertise type of thing
if it's a breaking legal matter I'll
just call like a friend who's a lawyer
or call a friend who's a doctor or
something like that if it lends itself
to that let me ask you about the nature
of Truth do you think it's becoming more
and more difficult to know what is true
and will become continuously continue to
get more difficult especially with GPT I
think the big difficulty
is in getting people to agree as to what
is a statement of fact and what is a
statement of opinion I think once we can
do that reasonable people can more or
less agree on how to get to the truth or
if we can't get to it at least figure
out how we would if the information were
available but the at the bigger
challenge I'm having is
someone will call in with an opinion
but say they want to talk about fact
and I have to explain to them you're
talking about an opinion and not a fact
and this goes back to the lack of
critical thinking and lack of media
literacy uh but that's the bigger
challenge for me right now but I mean I
think the big statements are always
going to be somewhat opinions
like um
was the
palek was the 2020 election Fair
I think any answer to that is an opinion
I disagree if we Define fair
well yes so then I don't think it's
possible to Define fair in a way that's
not several paragraphs where each
sentence it now has has facts right
right so you what do you mean by fair is
it uh who can show up to vote what was
the process of how easy it is to vote uh
was there actual uh cheating going on in
different like what is the evidence of
that cheating you have to actually get
to the actual like details of a thing
high level
know uh everything is just going to be
an opinion it feels like
and you can approximate that to be like
it's a well-founded opinion well most of
science is an opinion even physics is an
opinion so like I think there's a
threshold Beyond which an opinion
becomes like uh this is a pretty
reliable thing to assume for now that
this is okay so let me revise so I think
maybe better said
I think that the difficulty
I mean it is the process you described
is probably the right process and is
it's exhausting for mundane things and
that causes major problems if we were to
say
is it better for the economy to have a
tax rate on people making over a million
dollars that's 20 or 50 okay what do we
mean by better for the economy
it's not an overwhelming task to decide
on that we could say well we'll say it's
better for the economy by looking at
what was the unemployment rate based on
the tax rate on million you know people
earning a million a year and what was
GDP and whatever okay we've we've agreed
this is a statement we are now in the
realm of just determining what is given
the parameters that we've established I
think that that's that's relatively
doable the issue
is with the bigger ones like you're
talking about where what do we mean by a
fair election and fair in whose eyes and
but I I am with you that it often
devolves into a conversation about
opinions about what is fair rather than
an ascertainment of the facts yeah and
it feels like maybe avoiding some of
these big
maybe there's some trigger words too
maybe avoiding them allows you to
actually talk about the facts and
through that educate yourself and learn
about like uh whether the virus leaked
from a lab or not
to me it was always a super interesting
question I don't know why I already got
super touchy about it uh most of the
people I know colleagues biologists
thought
it's pretty good likelihood that a leak
from a lab given everything they just
didn't the evidence is not there for a
either one and so like you should be
able to just openly talk about it unless
you're in the uh High political office
where there could be geopolitical
consequences to your statements but in
general it's an interesting question you
should be able to talk about it but
there's no first of all there's not many
facts around there unfortunately
and a lot of the conclusive statements
about especially in the early days were
just opinions and so you have to
the idea of what is true and uh becomes
a little
even mentioning the word truth in that
context it feels um
divisive yeah I completely agree with
you which is strange like it really you
you think it shouldn't one of the really
good opening questions that I've had
worked to my advantage when talking with
people who I know disagree with me about
a contentious topic is how do you think
we would figure out X
and it often gets people thinking first
collaboratively and obviously we might
have very different opinions but with
something like the covet lab leak I
think it's an interesting one because if
you say okay maybe at least maybe it
didn't how would we figure that out who
would we trust to weigh in on that what
evidence would count now we're kind of
on the same team and then if we can
establish that then we're on a search
for capital T truth together or whatever
it's kind of pie in the sky but in some
conversations I've actually had success
with that and then you can kind of
realize
if uh if there's no amount of evidence
that's going to prove a show to you that
you're wrong in your current opinion
that that's probably a really bad sign
for you it's a waste it may be a waste
to pursue the conversation further at
that point yeah yeah what oh so okay you
think Trump was a good president
how do you determine that and what
evidence might exist that would change
your mind there is no evidence Trump was
the best president ever I think the
conversation is probably done except
Abraham Lincoln right
uh you mentioned Israel Palestine well
what do you think about the situation in
Israel and Palestine something you've
thought about spoken about for quite a
time do you think we'll ever see peace
in this part of the world
I don't know you know I mean I could say
yes honest answer I could say yes I I
the you know one of the problems is and
I'll give you may not know that the
there are people on the left of my
audience who call me a Netanyahu shill
even though I've never been a supporter
of Netanyahu and I'm I'm on the left I
just don't think that some of the
uh kind of black and white
characterizations about Israel are even
remotely accurate and I think most
people it's become a sort of litmus test
are you criticizing Israel enough are
you showing us that you're actually
left-wing I don't do any of that stuff I
should really look at the situation for
what it is that's become a litmus test
in American politics uh in the spectrum
of American politics yes
um my view big picture is that uh I
don't
think we're going to really get anywhere
until
some
pre-negotiated terms are set and the
parties to do the negotiating are all
good faith parties for example I don't
think Israel's right-wing party likud is
a particularly good faith Arbiter of
Peace because I think likud benefits
from their not being peace and the
threat of violence and there is violence
it's not just the threat of violence I
don't think Hamas is going to be an
Arbiter of peace for the Palestinian
people either I think the Palestinian
Authority is a question mark I'm not
sure so I think that there need to be
some preconditions that would need to be
set with regard to everything from
settlements to a lot of this minutia big
picture though if I imagine what the
most likely solution looks like it
doesn't mean it's a perfect solution and
obviously it's a solution many people
will say it's not it's not going to
happen I think it's a solution where the
borders are similar to what was being
discussed in the Clinton era to some
degree as many of the settlements as
possible have to go understanding that
some of the bigger ones are just not
going to go and there's going to have to
be meaningful land swaps with which
Yasser Arafat seem to be amenable to
when he weighed in on it I believe it
was in the 90s the topic of the Temple
Mount and Jerusalem Etc is a complicated
one but I think that almost certainly
um East Jerusalem is going to have to be
part of an eventual Palestinians day you
know I mean like we can go as kind of as
far as as we want to with a lot of this
stuff what role does us have to play in
this coming to the table with good faith
parties I don't know whether the I go
back and forth between believing that
the U.S should play a big role to the
U.S should play essentially no role
whatsoever because uh of course of the
funding of Israel that the U.S provides
will the you I don't it's not that I
have a personal problem with American
involvement and somebody like Bill
Clinton was arguably relatively well
positioned to try to make something
happen it's more just will there will it
be seen as credible on the global stage
and that's I think the most important
thing because at the end of whatever
negotiation takes place both sides need
to agree that this is where we are
renouncing all past claims and in the
future if there's a disagreement we
can't go back to that thing from the 80s
or the 90s that's just like a critical
piece of this yeah it has to be stable
and uh
you know
um materialize into something stable
over years yes
another
difficult conflict going on in the world
is the war in Ukraine what do you think
about the Russian invasion of Ukraine in
February 2022
I don't pretend to be an expert on this
issue I think you probably know more
about this than I do just from the brief
conversation we had before we started
filming my view as a general Observer of
geopolitics and the way that this area
this part of the world is related to
American Presidents over the last
several you know Cycles is I don't think
it's controversial to say that this was
a war of aggression an invasion of
aggression and active aggression by
Vladimir Putin
um I
do believe that
if Trump had been re-elected
Putin may have seen himself as having
other tools with which to try to
um expand influence that may have been
different than geographical uh Pursuits
Geographic Pursuits uh but I we don't
know that for sure
I also have a really hard time imagining
what the end of this looks like and
that's very scary because
sometimes the most benign end seems to
be that Putin ends up out of power
either through no longer being alive
or deposed in some way it doesn't feel
like that ladder is super likely the
former there's reports about his health
I don't know how accurate they are it's
just hard to imagine a face-saving exit
that is going to be
um even remotely uh what's the word it's
not even a question of acceptable just
um it's not satisfying either just just
not tragic I guess is what I'm looking
for in terms of uh Putin speaking to the
Russian people and being able to figure
out what to say what kind of narrative
to say why this board made sense yes
um the same on the Ukrainian side to
figure out how to exit this war yes uh I
mean to some degree it requires Russian
troops leaving Ukraine and that is
somewhat under the control I mean if of
course it's not up to Ukraine whether
the initiative continues but what I am
not thrilled with are some of the
reflexive you know if Trump had been in
power instead of Joe Biden
a lot of the reflexive uh comments about
oh you're if you if you say Ukraine is
just acting defensively you're
supporting neo-nazis or some of these
things that have come out of the
American Republican Party
seem both wacky and like they would be
saying completely different things if
Trump happened to be in the Oval Office
they're really proxy attacks on Joe
Biden yeah well that in some sense
Ukraine is also kind of political litmus
test
how you speak about it I think because
of the huge amount of funding that's
going uh from U.S to Ukraine
um maybe you can correct me if I'm wrong
but it seems to
it seems to me that this topic has
become politicized already 100 there are
people like Marjorie Taylor green and
others saying we should be doing nothing
for Ukraine zolenski is a comedian and
we're supporting neo-nazis that's it
full stop and you either subscribe to
that
um or you don't and it very quickly
becomes
um it very quickly becomes as partisan
as so many other issues and it's really
the the most disappointing thing is that
some of these issues become incredible
devices divisive but they're simple like
for example a conspiracy theory that we
know isn't true it shouldn't be devices
divisive because it's so simple other
issues become divisive and they are
simplified but in reality they are
extraordinarily complex and you lose the
ability to talk about the complexity
because they're becoming partisan uh do
you think there will always be war in
the world
there's a bunch of folks in the
subreddit that were interested in your
different complex doesn't foreign policy
so let's talk about war
when you look at the war in Ukraine
you look at what's going on in Israel
and Palestine you look at the wars
across the world do you think there will
always be War as a redditor put it is it
a necessary evil in the game of
geopolitics I used to have what I now
believe is an extremely naive
perspective which is that if we some how
if Ali intelligent aliens arrived here
it would be so momentous for Homo
sapiens that all of our differences
would immediately be exposed to so
insignificant we would never fight again
and we would realize that intelligent
life and then I spoke to people who deal
in space exploration and other other
sciences and they all said that's David
that's extraordinarily naive there would
be a period during which this was as
momentous as you're imagining and then
it would become normal and then we would
go back to many of the same conflicts
that we have now sectarian
Etc I think that in all likelihood there
will always be
conflict between factions whether it's
what we currently think of as War
probably not I mean it seems as though
the tactics will evolve and it will be
less about missiles and I don't know
where it's going to go I don't know
whether it's going to become more
biological or cyber or certainly
something we haven't even considered yet
but I think there will always be
conflicts we would refer to in that way
do you agree with Charles key on the his
General harsh criticism of U.S foreign
policy in war that's
many actions military actions in the
United States are criminal in nature
almost terrorists in nature I am not
it's been a decade or more since I've
read any Chomsky and I don't keep up
with everything that he has recently
said so I don't want to mischaracterize
any of it in general Americans are
sold the view that were the good guys
spreading Freedom across the world and
knowing Chomsky takes a perspective that
yeah but if you look at the number of
civilians you kill while doing it it's
incomparable to any other military
actions across the world right so I very
much disagree with those who take the
view that the US is this
um wonderful Global police force that's
spreading democracy and fixing problems
very very much wrong
I think where I've had disagreements
with Chomsky in the past is more he
framed he seems to frame the us as a
uniquely bad actor in some of these
cases and I think it's more an
outcropping of the size and wealth of
the US and less about uniquely negative
intentions and so I think that would be
my general disagreement with Chomsky
based on stuff I read a decade well he
says that he lives the United States
he's an American and so he feels his
focus of criticism should be in America
and I think that's one of the great
things about being an American and being
in America
is the freedom to criticize harshly sure
while being a university Professor by
the way
um he's basically the embodiment of why
10 years a really valuable thing I agree
whether you agree with him or not a
question from Reddit
ask David what he plans for his garden
this year is this a joke or is it not a
joke I got into gardening a few years
ago
honestly I'm with the baby yeah I can't
do a garden this year it's just and I
have a lot of travel coming up so
everything would die but I did start to
try to figure out gardening if you're
stressed by the toxicity of the social
media World gardening is a great hobby
it really is
um but it is extraordinarily time
consuming so I have no Garden planned
this year
um other books uh or maybe movies in
your life
that had a big impact on you
that you know you're thinking about that
diet
has has there been stuff you read forget
it about even just books like blogs or
writers or just sources of information
that had
uh that molded you into the intellectual
into the political think there that you
are it's so hard this is sort of like
you know you win an Oscar and you you
want to make sure you thank all the
right people I I read so much and have
been reading for so long that it's
really hard to say but I think certainly
um for me narrative non-fiction
has been a fantastic genre to learn not
only about history but also about people
and psychology and very often when
people say I don't really read like what
can you recommend to me that might be
interesting all depending on you know
knowing them to some degree
I'll give recommendations there in terms
of of um just things I picked up
recently that that I think are
interesting
um I've been reading uh a bunch of Neil
Postman I read a Jenny O'Dell has a new
book on time and the concept of like
Saving Time spending time Etc she just
published it super interesting I just
read
um lansing's book about the Shackleton
Voyage in Antarctica in 1914 15 and 16.
super interesting I'm really all over
the map I have that one on audiobook
I've been me to listen to It's very
interesting and it seems inconceivable
how these guys survived it completely
inconceivable and yet they did
uh it kind of inspires you to think of
uh space exploration and taking on
similar kinds of risky and dangerous
Journeys uh in narrative nonfiction I
agree with you very much I've been
reading a lot of 20th century history
um about Stalin
and about Hitler rise and fall the Third
Reich I've read twice now and I
recommend
what did you get out of reading it the
second time
uh
so would I uh
uh so the second time I listened to the
audiobook okay as I ran I get the same
thing from it uh as I get maybe reading
uh man search for meaning which is um
All the Troubles of day-to-day in the
modern world kind of uh fade away and
dissipate when I'm thinking about the uh
you know basically the embodiment of
evil at scale
at that recent time in human history so
it's it makes me sort of appreciate all
the it fills me with gratitude to have
all the freedoms all the just simple
joys of life that we have today
and um
I think the second time I was as I was
reading it uh because William Shire was
there he's the the author he was
directed the whole thing you said to
pick up little details as opposed to
like big things you start to pick up the
little quirks
of uh how history terms and just like
these little events you notice of the
Dynamics between people in a room during
a meeting with Hitler you just notice
these little things that are mentioned
because like he was either there
directly or referred uh the next day so
you get that's why to me
um rise and fall the Third Reich is
interesting is because it's by a guy
who's there who's reporting on it
um versus a sort of a more distant uh
displaced every time and I also like
biographies I'm a big fan of biographies
and um Walter Isaac says she's wearing
some incredible ones and Steve Jobs and
and Einstein all that kind of stuff
um Victor Frankel's book is one I've
read a bunch of times yeah and it's so
short and yeah you know reading in
general I know a lot of people who read
way more than I do and I also know a lot
of people who don't read at all I mean
they haven't read a book since since
College essentially to me it's almost
like the amount I get from it it's
almost like a secret weapon where when I
think you know in two or three or four
hundred Pages which I can read in
whatever 10 days or however long it
takes reading 30 pages a day
the amount of information
insights into so many aspects of the
human psyche that I can get it's sort of
like it's not like I'm in a competition
for anything in particular with anybody
I just do my show but it's sort of like
if I'm reading dozens of books a year
and you're reading zero I'm exposed to
so many different things and ideas that
are not even in your Universe it just
seems like the the power of reading just
seems overwhelming
and I I had uh speaking of getting
attacked I had a fun time getting
attacked uh a few months ago for
publishing a reading list some um
reading at least a book A Week
read
um 18 or 19 books from the beginning of
the year and I got attacked for the
books you chose or for this is I don't
know for what oh but it got became quite
viral attack for reading that's that's
something uh so it's basically what
happened is that people I I actually
don't it it's not worth folks who know
Fair of folks who don't don't even worry
about it it's the what I really loved
about being attacked for it
is it shows you can get attacked for
anything apparently it's so it's not
like I did something wrong it was kind
of a beautiful thing and it was
uh the most intensely beautiful display
of absurdity of Twitter and the internet
that there would be there were articles
written about me with the book list
um there's no bad books on it the thing
I was being mocked for is reading
Dostoyevsky reading stuff that uh sounds
like a high school reading list oh I see
or all these kinds of aspects of the
reading list which
doesn't stand up to any sort of
legitimate kind of criticism but the
fact that people are just looking for
single words or single aspects of a
tweet and so on to criticize this yeah
and um actually forced me to because I
released a video about you know
summarizing my takeaways from from one
of the books and I've been meaning to do
more and more but every time I started
to like
want to record it
I have this negative feeling they kind
of ruin the fun of sharing with us I
know exactly what you're talking about
my advice on that is don't do it just
don't record it yeah because and and is
that what you did yeah but I I I think
time cures it but for now I decided not
to yes it's just until I'm until I feel
Joy when I do it yeah we are in such a
privileged position to even be able to
do this sort of thing right I have taken
on projects and then it sort of sounds
good or I end up doing it because
there's some third party that brings the
idea and I feel like I can't really say
no or whatever
and then when I get in front of the
camera or I have to write something for
a while I did a newspaper column that I
hated doing I realized that I'm ruining
the exact thing that I have worked to
build which is that I can just do
whatever I want why am I doing this and
sometimes it takes me a week to realize
it sometimes it takes me a year
but just don't do it that's the in this
case in particular it's also that
there's a private thing I enjoy which is
reading right and if sharing that
private thing you enjoy is not fun then
just don't share it that that's um
yeah there's certain things there's
certain private things that should
remain private
that's like which is one of the first
things ever I'm I'm the same person
probably as I am publicly but the books
it's like man I don't get to share I
guess through these conversations I can
uh share some of the stuff I'm reading
and enjoying it because it sucks it
sucks to get attacked for stuff and it
sucks to get attacked for stuff you love
yeah especially reading I mean it's uh
you know that's the the bottom of the
barrel I have these ideas where I'll go
you know maybe for my next thing I'll go
from politics which is so toxic I'll go
to travel blogging because I there's so
many travel bloggers I follow and
there's so many interesting places and
then I go wait a second I like traveling
and just hanging out now traveling is
going to be my job and now I've got to
bring two cameras with me and I've got
to get shots and I've got to film my
food and I'm not gonna do that I'm just
gonna do what I'm doing but then I'll
travel when I want to take a vacation
and of course some of it could be fun I
mean I I have to say when I did the one
video on a book in 1984 I really enjoyed
it that whole process was fun it was um
um
I don't think I've ever thought as hard
about a book when I had to make a video
about it because I had to like you know
I read 1984 I know many times probably
five ten times I don't remember
um I read Animal Farm way more uh but I
don't think I was like what do I think
about like what are the key takeaways
for me it I didn't really know like if
you ask me what I think about even
Animal Farm because I haven't done that
one and I've read that one I don't know
over 50 times it's probably my favorite
book it's like I would have to struggle
and making a video about it but
basically a little mini lecture yeah
forced me to actually have an opinion
about the details of it and to do enough
research to think like okay what is the
historical context of this book I mean
it it allowed me to say interesting and
to think interesting stuff about the
book I it was I found it to be really
rewarding to basically the old Feynman
thing uh one of the best ways to learn
is to teach yeah I can't think of one
thing I would say about animal farm and
I read it again not that long ago but I
don't know what comments you kind of
have a generic comment yeah like uh
authoritarianism and so on whatever yeah
but there could be interesting quirks of
the book and the characters and the how
uh how corruption happens you could you
could say all kinds of stuff that it may
be contrasting it like even with 1984 it
allowed me to contrast with Brave New
World and
um
and uh and how that 1984 was politicized
and how it's used by the Republican
party of today like you could say a lot
of interesting stuff if you like think
about it and write it down on a sheet of
paper maybe you don't need to make a
video about it so I found it to be
really rewarding in general so I I
probably will do more of it but not
always not as a mean professional just
like with the travel blog I agree with
that
I mean you get threatened a lot you get
attacked a lot online do you think about
your mortality
well the other day I went to the doctor
and he said you know next physical we're
going to be talking about a lot of new
things and so I was thinking about it a
lot that day yeah uh no I mean
um it's funny I like I recently did a
bunch of estate stuff yeah and when you
have intellectual property there's a
question of like okay I have my assets
but also
if I died tomorrow especially in a
particularly fiery death my YouTube
channel would probably for a while
generate more money because it would be
like oh my goodness this person died in
a terrible what happens with a future
Revenue stream and all these different
things and it got me thinking about
Legacy and about the fact that people
who do this sort of thing it's kind of a
new thing in a sense and so you know if
you work at ABC News at some point you
just retire and someone else fills in
for you
how does my career wind down given like
I don't actually know the answer I'm not
sure
um what is it I just one day stopped
posting videos
but all my content stays up getting
fewer and fewer views or do I delete
everything do I I don't know what it
what is the guy I mean so you my trip to
Ukraine because I knew I was going to
the front is the first time I did uh I
record a video if I die oh and I post it
and give instructions to uh to folks
what to do in the so like there's a
closure yeah but it's an interesting
process like what happened this year at
which point does GPT take over and
continue tweeting for David Packer well
the tweeting I care less about right now
unless blue becomes something
unbelievable I'm less worried about
Twitter but
some of my audience members have been
saying you know some of these tools
David are getting good enough that we
could clone your voice and also make it
match video and with scripts you could
just keep pumping out content even if
you were gone and I said now that I'm
interested in that I want to learn more
about
boy it's going to be a weird future uh
what advice do you have to young folks
that are facing this future
almost always it's some version of
start right away and that applies in so
many different ways sure so if you're
thinking about oftentimes the context is
people want to do what I do and I always
say Do not sit around for a year
thinking about lighting
this is how you never do anything and I
dozens of people who I felt obligated to
talk to on the phone because of a
personal connection I go through all the
advice and I can tell
they're not going to do it they just
they're it's already sounding too
complicated and so instead they'll sort
of say well I gotta get the right
Lighting in the right room and the best
thing you can do no matter what you're
doing is just start right away and that
applies in this business and in whatever
else you're doing if you want to learn a
new thing find a new hobby the ability
to get data right away about what's
working what's not working and whether
you even like this approach that you're
taking is so valuable and it will allow
you to iterate and the sooner you do it
the cost to a change of direction will
also be lower
if there's any I don't do like self-help
or generic advice type stuff but the one
thing that applies in so many situations
is situations is just try it right away
and iterate from there yeah start today
and then do it every day
or decide hey you know what I figured
out I don't actually want to do it
yeah considerate yeah uh well usually
you'll discover you you do
you think we'll make it out of the
century Humanity human civilization out
of the so like to 2100 yeah how much we
got 80 years
yeah uh 77s
you think so yeah uh what are the
biggest threats facing our civilization
um I I actually think that uh
if you believe
that we are on an inflection point of
sorts in changes to society and
acceleration of Technology Etc I think
it's really tough to know in 2090 what
will actually be the biggest threat so I
don't know it's so cliche to say nuclear
and climate change and another pandemic
technologically the world might look so
different than this yes
unimaginable what it means to be human
is unimaginable and also
um the degree that we make progress out
into space
is also unimaginable I think space is
super interesting and there's people on
both the left and right who for
different reasons are kind of not into
the whole space exploration thing the
people I hear from the ones on the right
think it's just kind of dumb the ones on
the left think it's an excuse not to fix
problems here I think also uh they say
it's the play thing of billionaires sure
which is another funny kind of concept
yeah I mean someone's got to pay for it
uh why not be people who have a lot of
money to to either be billionaires or
governments that are trillionaires or
somebody has to pay for big ambitious
moonshot projects to me the most
interesting thing is that
in getting closer to the next step of
space exploration we may well learn
things that can then be used to improve
circumstances here for me it's not one
or the other and I recently read a long
piece about
why why not Mars because it's terrible
in every way for supporting life okay so
like that's one perspective but still in
so exploring who knows what we might end
up learning so I I'm I'm big on it I
don't um share the view of some on the
left about it so I guess to add to your
advice to young people if a thing seems
terrible you still might want to
consider doing it I would say so yeah
how many things have seen I mean listen
there are so many trips where the day
before
I say
why am I doing this the jet lag I've
gotta do this and that and now who if my
guest host falls through I should just
stay and work and I go hold on
you do this every time yep just go you
never regret it you learn something you
try something I never regret the trip
hopefully applies to the conversation we
had today uh David I'm a big fan of
yours thank you so much for talking
today thank you for being patient with
me we tried to talk earlier
um please continue doing what you're
doing please uh continue being objective
and thoughtful and uh Fearless thank you
on the internet big fan of yours as well
I appreciate it
thanks for listening to this
conversation with David packman to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
Mahatma Gandhi
what difference does it make to the Dead
the orphans and the homeless
whether the Mad destruction is wrought
under the name of totalitarianism or in
the Holy Name of Liberty or democracy
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time